the fbi
has raided the apartment and office of
rudy giuliani
they have seized electronic devices and
this may be one of the most
consequential stories of our generation
this is the former president the
previous administration's
lawyer the lawyer i mean it's one thing
for the feds to go after a lawyer it's
nothing to go after the lawyer of the
guy who was just
president and that's what's happening it
has to do with whether or not or i
should say it has to do with the
an investigation into whether or not
rudy giuliani was lobbying the
government on behalf
of ukrainians though i think most people
are just going to look at this like
retaliation from the democrats they have
hated donald trump they've hated
his administration and now they're using
the doj
merit garland green lighting these these
warrants to go after those
they don't like and uh you know normally
i wouldn't say this normally that you
know my earlier segment did my main
channel i didn't say it was retaliation
but now i will say it is
because you look at what joe biden has
to say tonight he's reportedly
going to say that january 6 was the
worst attack
on the u.s since the civil war unused
democracy since the civil war so it's
very clear
they're going to use the full weight of
government to go after every person
who in some substantive way was
supporting the president
to certain degrees they've already we've
already seen the weird cult of vote to
say
don't hire these people it could start
there or it could be
you help donald trump fight impeachment
something like that
don't be surprised when the feds show up
at your door so we'll talk about this we
also got protests lighting up in
elizabeth city again more unrest
the judge has refused to release body
camera footage
in the shooting of of a black man these
stories are not going to stop
and the left is going to say you're
right the cops keep killing killing
people or
they're just going to keep exploiting
death and ignoring the actual crime and
tragedies in their own communities
because it's all political so
we're going to talk about this joining
us today of course it's jack murphy day
hey what's up tim
lids hello ian good to see you hey
everybody every other wednesday jack
murphy i'm back
hey do me a favor hit subscribe on my
youtube channel widget jack murphy live
on youtube we're coming up on 50k oh
nice very nice 50k
it feels real almost he feels real what
about you ian well
i'm ian crossland and you can follow me
at enchrome.com.net
yes thank you very much i'm sarah
patchell it's on twitter so i didn't
mean to cut you off there
no you didn't say something i'm sorry
i'm sorry
it's a mind meld yeah it's true that's
what it is a four-way mine meld
let's get mellow i'm sitting here not
saying anything you guys are doing part
of it
come on i was sitting here looking at my
japanese soda just like
i wonder what flavor this is it's called
original flavor sugar it's original
someone said four-way and tim's like
what's in the soda
i'm not interested well i walked in the
house today and he goes dude
dude we got a bunch of crazy soda flames
yeah yeah yeah we got huckleberry soda
yeah and cherry soda
cherry soda stuff it was funny you're
like i'm gonna put this in the freezer
and i heard you set the timer on alexa
20 minutes later
you're like you go man i hope it's cold
yeah
was it was it cold it was warm it wasn't
enough
i'm sorry slowly
we have a great sponsor today we are
sponsored by biotrust
mct oil powder this uh go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com you'll see the
link in the description below
and you can get 51 percent off this
really amazing mct
oil powder this stuff's awesome you mix
it in your drinks you put it in
you know mix your smoothies and stuff
and it is medium chain
triglyceride fats so for people who are
doing the keto diet notice they call it
the keto elevate
this is the kind of thing that your body
needs for fuel let me just tell you
something look i'm not a nutritionist or
a doctor
all right i try to cut out sugar to the
to the best of my ability believe it or
not the soda i actually have it's low
sugar
it's it's it's what's half the sugar of
coke i'm not i'm not doing keto i'm not
like
totally no sugar but i try to do a
balance where i get at least a little
bit
less like a decent amount less sugar and
avoid that and try and do more fat in my
diet
so if you're someone who's paying
attention to this stuff you want to you
know ian i know you don't like sugar
dude
but that mct oil is amazing yeah
yes all right anyway back to the promo
go to eatrightandfeelwell.com and you
can get 51
off of your supply they say yes the keto
diet works wonders is according to
biotrust for boosting metabolism
elevating energy and enhancing mental
focus
but it's also incredibly difficult to
follow that's why you just buy some of
this you throw it in your drinks your
coffee or smoothie whatever
we got some talking points for you
really cool stuff you get a 60-day
money-back guarantee
they say enhanced energy levels healthy
appetite management
enhanced mental clarity and focus
athletic performance
keto elevate is very gentle on your
stomach five grams
of the highly sought after mctc8 per
scoop
keto elevate is the most advanced mct
powder on the market today
free shipping on every order and for
every order today biotrust will donate a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor
through their partnership with no kid
hungry.org to date biotrust has provided
over 4.4 million meals to hungry kids
please help biotrust hit their goal of 5
million meals this year
free vip live health and fitness
coaching from biotrust team of expert
nutrition and health coaches for life
with every order and a free new e-report
the top 14 ketogenic foods with every
order keto's super popular right now
yeah i really implore you talk to your
doctor and
check out you know everything you're
supposed to be doing sometimes you know
it's really between you and your health
practitioner but this stuff's really
awesome because regardless of whether
you're actually trying to do the keto
diet this is just healthy stuff you can
put your drinks
so special thank you to biotrust again
go to eatrightandfeelwell.com
51 off and don't forget head over to
timcast.com to become a member
because we're going to have an exclusive
members only segment and it's going to
get real dark because we were talking
earlier in the show
and ian was like dude we can't talk
about this stuff on youtube it's just
too spicy
war and chaos and conflict and we're
alive but we should we should have that
conversation later
so we're going to get into a really
serious uh show
yeah talking about warren conference
stuff so this will be around 11 pm we
normally put it up but go to timcast.com
you click the members only button
you can sign up then you go to the
members area and you'll see the post is
there we have a huge library of content
and i got great news because we're going
to be integrating stripe very soon which
means more payment options going to be
fantastic
easier for all of you we are we are
setting up the newsroom we are talking
with potential new writers it is going
to be a blast but let's jump into that
first
major story here it is from eyewitness
abc 7 the latest update
fbi seizes electronics from rudy
giuliani's manhattan apartment
they say federal agents carried out a
search warrant at the home and office
of former new york city mayor rudy
giuliani wednesday morning sources
familiar with the matter confirmed abc
news
sources tell abc news electronic devices
including giuliani's cell phone
were confiscated by authorities a
spokesperson
and attorney for giuliani have not
responded to abc news wednesday
afternoon giuliani's son
andrew who was mulling a run for new
york governor spoke briefly outside his
father's apartment
quote any american red or blue should be
extremely disturbed by what happened
here today
this is disgusting this is absolutely
absurd and it's the continued
politicization
of the justice department that we have
seen and it has to stop
if this can happen to the former
president's lawyer this can happen to
any american
they say the warrants were in relation
to the justice department's
investigation
into the business dealings of former
president donald trump's personal lawyer
notably according to the new york times
it was uh far a violation so was he
acting as a forward agent lobbying on
behalf of ukrainians
to donald trump or was this
retaliation not only are they going
after rudy giuliani but according to the
wall street journal they are trying to
find communications between giuliani
and journalist john solomon you may
recall
the previous controversy when i think it
was adam schiff right who was spying on
an american journalist
because he didn't like the information
that was being published and i guess he
actually published private information
from solomon it's been a while since
we've covered that story
but my friends uh what what do you say i
don't know banana republic are we
are we there is it happened already
there was a time in my
lifetime where if the fbi and the doj
served a warrant and they confiscated a
bunch of documents and equipment and
stuff my first instinct would have been
they probably have a good reason to do
that
today my instinct is they just trying to
get everybody that had anything to do
with donald j
trump period because we see it across
the board we see it with the january 6
folks
we see it with people in the military
people and police you're not allowed to
even have
donated to kyle rittenhouse's legal
defense fund
anything that you do that runs contrary
to what they want you to do
is going to put you at risk heaven
forbid you work with the president
you help the president yeah they want to
get in there they want to see his
communications they want to see his
documents i mean look
go ahead no they've gone after people's
jobs they've already we've already seen
from the establishment
don't let anyone get a job if they
worked with the presidential with
trump's administration
so that's like the lowest level of it
you're a trump supporter get out don't
wear the maga hat
you believe you're crazy you're a white
supremacist now it's it's
that elevates to anybody who's ever
worked the trump administration you'll
never be allowed to work again
or at least in their system which is why
it's so important that we build our own
networks but then you see what happens
with big tech and the media
so i'm a little pessimistic now i mean
we had some we had some good stuff
you know like the falcon and winter
soldier i was all excited i was like the
ending of that show is great
you know this guy takes the american
flag and beats antifa with it
but that's just the tv show that's not
justice where we watch what happens with
the chauvin trial
they're they're walking these jurors
through riots with security with with
with you know with and what what what
did andrew say they had
uh mp5s or something yeah i think so
whatever guns they were using
uh they were using very serious weapons
to protect the jurors
one of the jurors actually lived in the
city where riots were happening there's
no justice
and we're watching this across the
country now it's happening again then
you get a story where it's the former
previous president's lawyer is being
raided by the doj
as soon as merrick garland gets in
appointed by joe biden
there it is green light go after those
who opposed us you think merrick
garland's got a bone to pick
i would say so with giuliani just in
general right with the republicans in
general right
i think we are watching the the cult
take over
yeah it's been happening for some time
it's everywhere it's in everything it's
in every nook and cranny of every agency
every bureaucracy every every
bureaucracy cop chapter every
institution every everything and it's
like at some point
you we just have to accept it i still
even in this work that i do and the
conversations that i have and the
research and the people i talk to
i still am a little shocked each time
i still am a little saddened each time
i still feel like a bit of my optimism
and my
my idealization of america is still
there
and so each time this had just chip so
like when
when am i going to become totally black
pill this is the question
and it hasn't happened yet where like
the next thing that happens happen and
i'm like oh yeah
totally unsurprised there's two big
issues
the first is that the the you know the
the cult the the establishment cronies
have attained such a level of power that
they can literally do this
when donald trump you know chants lock
her up at this rallies they're screaming
like oh heavens
oh we cannot be a country that threatens
to to
to send the legal system against our
political rivals
what's that trump's out of office send
the legal system after our political
rivals indeed
that's exactly but the other thing is
the unwillingness of americans to stand
up for
the principles of this country so before
before the show we were talking about
like local police departments and i'll
tell you i guarantee you
you will have a bunch of cops right now
who are going like man
i get it you know these guys are saying
how bad it's getting and i totally
recognize the corruption in office
we got to do something about it then his
boss walks in and he says
johnson go arrest jack murphy for
sedition he goes you got it boss
hey jack go to prison for the rest of
your life and you're like what i'm doing
what i'm told because i don't care
so long as regular people just go along
with whatever the insane garbage is
it's not it's not going to change well
the problem with the police department
is you've got people that go in who are
true believers who might now become
cynical and not want to participate
then you got people that are doing it
because it pays better than their next
best alternatives
and it barely pays and it barely pays so
now you add
this extra pressure to it you're not
going to get the idealist
you're not going to get the people with
better options you're gonna get people
with even worse options
saying this is my best choice to enter
in this position that basically
everybody hates no one wants a round
and you have to go do terrible dirty
work on people you're gonna get goons
it's like venezuela these these the
venezuelan soldiers are like eh
i get food if i do what you know maduro
wants
and if i don't i don't get any food
literally don't get it if i don't
see this this is the thing that the the
establishments cult like you know woke
left and
corporate neoliberal people understand
way better than conservatives
it's that there is no loyalty among the
average person
to any of their fellow countrymen they
know that which means
you can literally have fbi agents who
are lying man this is freaking me out
and they go
now go arrest him okay boss whatever
gleefully being like i swear an oath to
the constitution
is that a gun to prison with you that's
that troubles me dude it troubles me
that you say
and i agree with and then i ask why why
does your why do your citizens feel no
loyalty to their fellow citizens
if that's not the case then
the citizenry is too broad
i think uh man we're we're
a gluttonous lazy people that has for
too long
maybe maybe this past couple of
generations have had no real struggle
you know just sitting around enjoying
the the
uh fruits of the previous wars and the
labor of the previous generations
now we've got you know fat homeless
people that's like how prosperous this
country is
so now they become lazy and just like i
don't want to sacrifice my
my comfort for you so you will get
right now like cops who swear an oath of
the constitution
and then violate the constitution every
single day and say yeah whatever well in
their mind their oath
is to the constitution but their oath is
to the guy who's giving them orders
right in their mind it's like the
constitution
orders okay i do what they say yeah i'm
not a lawyer i don't i mean i'm just
projecting i mean i don't really know
it's true
we had andrew uh on last night yeah and
he was talking about
that the chief police is a politician
once you get to that level of the law
enforcement you become a politician and
they basically are political
we want to think of it as a civil civil
movement but the police are basically
answering to the politicians and if the
politicians go in a political
direction the police but but it's it's
the individual officer who can say no
right right so i don't want to derail
too much we're talking about you know
giuliani
and and the point at which the federal
government now is arresting its rivals
so let's go back in time
let's go back in time to what 2017
i think it was when we started seeing
when was the berkeley the battle for
berkeley was that 2017
it was after the election yeah yeah milo
was there
and yeah so at this point you're seeing
these clashes and the proud boys show up
that was bike lock day wasn't it i think
that was 2017. yeah but then it happened
again for the next year or so
yeah and over the next year i started
talking about i remember i was talking
to a bunch of dc
commentators and conservative
journalists and i was like
this is scary because the escalation of
this is civil war
and then you know immediately i get
pushed back from these conservative you
know dc folks who are like oh come on
it's just a bunch of people fighting in
the street and i said listen
at what point does this escalate further
and further until it reaches the highest
level of government
no that's never going to happen the
security state is strong it won't allow
collapse blah blah blah
pretty sure when the doj seizes the cell
phone
of the previous president's lawyer you
you're seeing
the breakdown sorry it's it's there you
go
i mean i know we've had i know we've had
crazier with like nixon and watergate
and stuff
or i shouldn't even necessarily say
crazier because maybe it wasn't
maybe it was just crazy and maybe now
when you combine
the years of street conflict the years
of media manipulation
the lies and the the foreign collusion
interference all the crazy whatever
with now that joe biden is in power he
brings in
garland mayor garland goes after the
trump administration i don't think we've
seen anything this crazy
since the civil war and it's just
getting started
so the united states has been abroad
as a foreign occupying force fighting
counter insurgency battles against the
insurgents that are trying to expel
the government from their occupation
that's exactly what they're going to do
here now
they are a hammer we are the nails and
this is going to be
the war on terror 3.0 but it's really
the war on drugs it's really the war on
americans this is a war on americans 1.0
and they're going to use the entire
apparatus that they've developed over
two decades now
of being an occupying force and
squashing descent they're going to use
it here
in the united states and dude we
predicted this at
you know at the end of last year and now
it's happening and now tonight is the
night
joe biden's going to go on tv he's going
to call all the 400 people they've
arrested in january 6th is the
insurgents responsible for
the most egregious attack on our
democracy since the civil war
they've already shown that they're
trying to filter out the uh the armed
forces
the police everyone else if you just had
any inclination to support trump or kyle
rittenhouse or anybody else
they're coming after all of us the
detrompification is a real thing
why we can't let this happen again
we have this article over the daily mail
i will turn peril into possibility biden
will
attack trump with his speech to congress
by saying he inherited a nation in
crisis
after the worst attack on our democracy
since the civil war wow i can't believe
he would say some strong words about a
year of anti-variety and
two billion dollars in damage you know
just the other day uh a week or so ago
in oklahoma city
black lives matter stormed the capitol
building yeah so it's good for a joke oh
wait what's
hold on oh he wasn't talking about i'm
being handed a note uh he's talking
about
trump supporters
those are the good guys dude guys all
dressed in black those are the good guys
yes
really you ever see that yourself i
can't remember who the comedians was by
where they're like
dressed as nazis and then he like looks
down and sees the skull and crossbones
and he goes
are we the baddies oh yeah yeah like
you're using a skull in the crossbow
okay so that's the comedy show the name
just escaped me but those two guys from
england
hilarious history nerds yeah totally on
point
super funny and they would recreate
these world war two things and he that
moment
he looks he goes are we the baddies he's
got the because they're wearing the
skull and crossbones
well so you look at what's going on now
with antifa smashing and destroying but
what's funny to me is they smash and
destroy starbucks and starbucks is like
we're glad they did this
and in fact thank you for destroying our
bathrooms anybody who wants to come in
and use the bathrooms at any time now
customers otherwise doesn't matter
anybody you can now use our bathrooms
have you been in a starbucks bathroom
since they did that i mean
no it's like a homelessness but you know
you know what man yeah i'm i'm kind of
chilling
uh everything is like being lit up
around me and people seem to think that
there's potentially going to be a
federal takeover of police but i
really don't think so how many fbi
agents are there there's no way they can
handle
there's like 800 thousand to a million
cops around the country i really don't
think the feds can take that over maybe
they can try
or maybe what's really going to happen
is once the police departments go
under then there's no local enforcement
laws become
irrelevant to the average person and
then the country just doesn't exist in a
meaningful way anymore
what's going to happen is the talent
level of the police officers is going to
degrade
so poorly because no one with any other
options is going to take that job
that the the police may be there but
they will be so
ineffective and just able to be pushed
around they'll just it'll be worthless
so federal policing will become
more how though how what do you mean how
many uh uh are there
so so maybe maybe just seeing like the
singling out the fbi
is a little uh short-sighted because
other agencies fps for instance
ice cbp there's not nearly enough
federal law enforcement to handle the
entire country oh yeah no no
red states are immediate like people in
rural areas are like nah yeah
so so without local law enforcement
federal law is
going to be wait wait has there been has
there been sounds about a federal police
force
well a lot of people have been chatting
us saying like if the right if the local
cops go
the feds step in or private police hired
by the feds oh well private police
oh i don't know about hired by the feds
but private police has been prophesized
for a long time especially neil
stephenson snow crash
many many many years ago about ghettoed
ghettoed in in the technical sense like
isolated neighborhoods with their own
police departments and known security
departments
et cetera that's definitely coming
anybody with money is going to be hiring
security so so let's talk about the two
potentials right that's the scary
scenario if they abolish the police and
then bring about their cult
as the local officers we're we are on
on a track that heads towards a
totalitarian cult organ
government driving through a town and
then they they stop
you and you don't know why they're
stopping you or what's going on and they
throw you in like a prison never to be
heard from again
because that's their local mm-hmm and
only you can only hope the feds come and
get you out somehow you can't hope the
feds are gonna do anything that's all
you have
to look look at what joe biden is doing
if anything
you're going to be crossing your fingers
that you make your way through a local
town that's crazy because if you go
through a red state there's going to be
a guy who's like
excuse me sir what are you doing here
and you're going to be like just passing
through and i'll be like okay mind you
keep mine to yourself and have a good
day
it's the feds who are going to be like
what's your excuse me sir pull over i
couldn't help but notice you're a white
man can you give me your pronouns for
your for your citation
what's that you don't oh you're under
arrest then you go to jail
i'm nervous about this because also
because if the local cops do resign
they'll get they're the ones that would
be first in order to get hired by
private companies if they're residing
though if they're resigning that's
because
it should be a statement of position
right they don't support the score look
no no no no that is all i think getting
a bit too
uh too far away from the big picture
here the big picture is
a cop right now can watch
their city being burnt to the ground and
be like i don't care
and then when you literally have cops
getting or getting getting arrested and
charged
and then they'll look at you and be like
sir is that a gun let's see let me check
let me take the bill of rights second
amendment well we don't need that one
you're under arrest
that's amazing to me that they would
that that cops will swear off the
constitution
and then look at it and go uh whatever
guess not meanwhile
they can't arrest the extremists the
charges get dropped the left uses the
fact the charges are being dropped as
evidence they're morally right and the
state is wrong
and they have two billion dollars worth
of damage and only a few cities
over the past year with all the damage
and destruction then you're gonna get
people like juan williams and fox news
saying
cities didn't burn down that's a lie
right people truly people
don't believe that that happened truly
people in washington dc believe
that the boarded up businesses
on january 5th were because
that the maga rioters had come through
the city all summer and destroyed
everything
they truly like honest to god truly
believe it to the point where
i present them with alternative facts as
in i was literally there i saw with my
own eyes
like not hearsay and they're like
whatever it blocked me on facebook like
they just
literally cannot accept the fact that
that was the case you need
only what was it who said this i don't
know if it was like a linsky or mark or
something you need like 11 percent of
the population to adhere
maybe it wasn't those guys maybe it was
a different researcher you need like 11
of the population to adhere to an
ideology to take over the entire country
because regular people they will sell
their own mothers like i i genuinely
believe the cops who remain in like
minneapolis
and and these cities are the kind of
people that would sell their mom for a
quick buck
i feel the urge myself to criticize some
of the law enforcement today but i also
feel the urge to defend some of them
there is something to be said for
wanting to try to do your best to make
change from the inside
and yeah you can't you can't make change
from the inside when you're under the
boot of
of corrupt politicians true but there
are
and i know them personally there are
still
good people who are police officers who
are trying to uphold the constitution
who are trying to do the best
but they're being forced into untenable
situation and it soon
soon very soon is going to come a point
in which they have to decide whether or
not
they're going to make a statement by
resigning or it's already happening or
maybe they have to go undercover in a
sense
and like subvert their own views
outwardly
in order to be in a position to make
change at some point in time
a sleeper cell if you will throughout
the country we are seeing
the good cops say no i won't do this
and in many cities many major democrat
urban metros
they're saying you give me a stick i'll
beat my own mom with it i don't care
just give me a paycheck
i'll do whatever you say for money
that's what they're doing you get that
guy on cnn the dc capital cop
oh you know doing that interview these
these are these are these are
look corrupt people exist there's a lot
of them
the good cops in my opinion have said no
and are refusing to abide by
this insanity and then you have you you
have i guess the banality of evil
in those who are like if we just get
through the storm it'll be okay so i'll
do it they tell me for now but maybe
things will get better meanwhile
the politicians are getting worse the
cases keep happening the system is being
destroyed there's no justice
why are why why is the system being
propped up at this point i'm just like
we need personal responsibility back we
need the sooner we have personal
responsibility
the sooner communities know that they're
responsible for themselves the better
but it's not going to happen so long as
you have people who want a paycheck who
aren't going to back who aren't going to
back down like uh well that's never
going to change so what are we going to
do
you can always pay people i mean how we
didn't we that's
our revolution was was f was like fought
in part by hired guns bassian's yeah
yeah bringing some german-hired guns
help us out
so the issue the bigger picture issue
right now is
no community in this country
no willingness to stand up for your
ideals your principles and your your
fellow countrymen
well there are a number of counties
let's say in a local state here nearby
virginia for example who decided to
stand up to their own governor and their
own legislature when they were trying to
pass laws that would infringe on the
second amendment
they put out statements they said we
will not honor these laws we will not
respect these laws
west virginia even passed a resolution
saying these counties in virginia that
wanna
maybe you wanna secede from your blue
psychopath blackface aborting baby
killing
emmer effort northam and virginia maybe
you wanna secede from that state you can
join us in west virginia
i think there are still jurisdictions
where you can find the kind of people
that are going to uphold the
constitution and do what we think is the
right thing to do right i'm talking
about the major urban metros yeah well
they're
toast right so i'm not i'm not talking
about cops in
in i'm not talking about sheriff's in
west virginia it's a useful distinction
right i'm talking about in minneapolis
where like they're sitting there in a
burning building going this is fine
i'm like dude that's the beam get out
stop
letting them get like do these things
and so the other
the other big issue is especially with
the federal government with what we saw
with you know giuliani
look what the fbi is doing to these
people some of these bumbling dotards
who like walked through a door confused
and bewildered at the capitol
some people a large portion did storm
their way in and were fighting cops
there's a video i watched from the fbi
where like
a guy grabs a cop's mask and is shaking
his head violently and i'm like that's
messed up
that guy should get arrested don't do
that but there are some people who are
bewildered
befuddled and just like walk through an
open door waving a little american flag
while the cops waved to them and
guided them in the building and the fbi
is like
tell us who these people are we're going
to arrest all of them you ain't seen
nothing yet and then antifa shows up and
burns down a bunch of buildings and
they're like that's all right
it's all right it's not all right it's
not all right
the system is completely broken the cult
is taking over and there
and with biden in power as president
going after giuliani oh there it is
so people like to say i wonder if the
reason why many of these lefties are
like
through wars because they don't want you
they don't want people to realize we're
in one
we are in a cold civil war that cold
doesn't mean it's not happening
cold means it's being it's not being
fought with
live ammunition when the government
steps up and starts arresting
or seizing the cell phone of the former
president's lawyer
like okay this is this is this is this
is this is the patriot act
but it is being fought with live
animation because when we write
missions cop chopping aluminum
ammunitions continue
please when history is written about
this they're going to include
ruby ridge in waco texas in the
chronology of this
experience right that is a hot
conflict right well you've also got
antifa
black lives matter and proud boys and
right-wing groups and the clashes
totally so it's taken two so as you've
talked about i've talked about plenty
it's definitely fourth or fifth
generation warfare this is exactly
what's happening where you've got
disparate decentralized groups
acting in uh in accordance or sort of
incoherence
uh trying to achieve a plausible promise
that can be achieved
they come together they work towards
that promise it works or doesn't then
they dissipate and they come back
together again we saw the network
alliance
this last summer between the
corporations the radical left the blm
and antifa we see a little bit of that
splintering
after the election with antifa still
being like f biden we want anarchy all
this stuff but nobody's really paying
too much attention to that part
so the civil war is on man it's on
the patriot act basically set the stage
i remember when that got signed and
thinking like this is so ridiculous like
not i didn't laugh but i was like
this is this is so insane that now the
government has the right to just like
bust in my door and throw me in
guantanamo bay
they don't but like i said
there are people who are going to be
like there's going to be some you know
federal agent looking at this going man
this is
crazy do you see the thing they just
signed and then
the door opens up hey johnson go beat
the crap out of that guy and throw him
in prison you got a boss but it took
18 years like it wasn't acted on for the
first decade or two obama
what i'm saying is they don't need it
they could go right now to the average
cop and be like brutally beat that
person and they'll say okay
they'll just do it it it really concerns
me that they legalized that kind of
thing
and then they waited like 15 years and
now they're starting to
do these like and going after
giuliani let me stop you again that's
irrelevant well
you you they going after giuliani is
with or without the patriot act
right the point is the political our
culture targets the
the community in this country the
culture in this country has been
shattered a long time ago and now you've
got people saying i don't care
i will enforce whatever you say it's
just easier that way
people wonder why you know just
following orders in in world war ii
journey why would they do it because
man people don't care they literally
don't care
there's no principle behind many of
these people now hold on
a lot of these cops they quit a lot of
them say i don't want to do this
but many of them who remain don't care
and i know there's a lot of them
probably conflicted but it's not just
about the police
it's about federal law enforcement it's
about people in the military
who would would show up and follow
whatever order because
well i don't know what you know i don't
have the information
you know i i've talked i i've lived on a
few different military uh bases
uh used uh well just off of use this and
i briefly
was crashing in fort carson because i
family who's there
and i asked some of the uh lower you
know enlisted guys and men and women
if you were told if you were given the
order to shoot somebody would you do it
and they were like well yeah like
you don't have all the information they
don't give you a pamphlet like
identifying the individual and what's
going on they say
stop that person now you do so it's not
an issue it's the banality of evil
it is not that individuals are like i'm
going to be evil today it's their boss
comes in and says
go arrest ian they go you got a boss
well they're like wait they're like hold
on sir is this in triplicate
okay it's in triple kid all right i got
it that's like the um the eight
we're like ancestors of apes we're just
these like we're we're really barely
out of what would you say salt water
monkey bodies yeah basically the animal
kingdom man we're in it
we are animal whether we want to think
of ourselves as like this evolved
thinking machine
isn't an animal anymore who thinks of
themselves as that dude i think of
myself as top of the food chain that's
what i think we're communal animals
and so we tend to follow the herd and
the pack and we go where their food is
going to be
and so when when they threaten to take
away the money or the food
i mean that's scary well not only that
but you touched on the real issue
social exile social shame
fear of being excluded fear of becoming
the worst thing
possible a member of the out group
because you will die alone in the woods
that's right don't want to be the out
group
doesn't even matter what the out group
is you don't want to be it bro
and so as long as the cult has
corporate press no matter how much they
lie
people are desperate to follow the
narrative of the of the
you know the dude playing the the pied
piper bro you got to give it to a man
they won they won all the media
all the institutions all the narratives
corporations the government the
narratives your thought processes your
value system
everything they won they totally won it
will now
take people willing to be part of the
out group
in order to fight back against this and
that willingness to be part of the
outgrouping
involves being financially in the out
group economically in the out group
politically in the out group socially in
the out group
you have to be willing to be a pariah
and an independent operator
in order to withstand what's happening
and just to survive
and maintain your sense of self and your
in your sense of identity
but to fight back holy crap you need to
be able to amass
resources you need to be able to amass
teammates in a way
that's still outside of the system
you're not going to go
down to your local college like round up
a bunch of guys that are going to see
things the way we do
and most people are going to
duck and say i hope the fire passes
overhead
and then within a few weeks there's a
burnt christmas you imagine they're like
uh you're no longer allowed to have a
bank
but you need to pay property taxes on
your house can't pay don't have money
they're
gonna take your house already yeah then
they seize property so you try and be
outside the system but the system's
still gonna come for you
unless you're on some distant planet
which isn't feasible at this stage
unless people start speaking up refusing
to participate in a game in which they
know their opponents are cheating
but instead they're like i don't know
you know i'm good for now
i'll just shut up and just take what i
can get you're right speaking up is key
but also building like the founding
fathers we kind of talked about this
before the show
they spent two decades writing it out
like creating
it was like a century like organizing a
database in a plan
so in addition to speaking up to have
the basic you know
the technology basically you know what i
was really feeling jealous of
earlier was like in the old days like
the really old days
you'd be like i hate this place i'm out
of here
and you can just roll off to some
wilderness yeah
there's nowhere there's nowhere to go
now
every place has been conquered every
place as well it's entirely true
what where are you going to go where
there's lawlessness where you could set
up your own country
i mean set up your own country if you're
one person and you kind of want to be
left alone mexico's got a lot of
territory
yeah there's a lot a lot of places in
mexico where you can go and kind of do
you think that's that anarchist place
you know what what state is that that
luke loves
uh an archipoca no that's just the name
of her
that's just the name of like a
conference yeah i can't remember the
name there's
like a southwestern uh i can't remember
the name of it but luke is like
it's it's anarchy this this town kicked
out the government and the cops and now
it's totally anarchy well that's cool
but they better have a lot of guns
the narcs the narco uh narco terrorists
want to roll through there and take back
their power you better be able to defend
yourself but what do the people have
that they would want
it doesn't matter my point is it's like
where truly can you just go and chill
not really anymore i mean you tell me
build an island all right yukon
territory alaska
yeah that's probably true alaska is red
yeah dude you can just
show up to middle alaska and just take a
bus in there and then live in an old bus
and then eat the wrong colored seeds and
die yep
so what was that movie into the wild
yeah
you can go to alaska man it's beautiful
a lot of fish still got that [ __ ] still
got the fbi in alaska yeah
but they're not going to go up to alaska
and bother you if all you do is fish all
day and you mind your own business
but if you speak up if you're loud they
might start yeah but that's you
and like i'm saying if you want to just
get away and you're like i don't want to
be a part of this anymore ain't nobody's
going to stop you
you can easily just go up to i mean dude
you can go to the middle of nebraska
even
there's definitely sure i mean
eventually someone might not knock on
your door and you'll be like i'm just
some dude eating a fish leave me alone
they probably will i think there's a
movement to make sure that it gets
harder and harder to get
to run away you still got to pay
property taxes in alaska bro
i bet i bet unless you're just some dude
who lives in a bus
i get i get it though if you have a
family but but to your point about being
able to just up and leave
you can it's just really really hard
yeah it was really hard to get in a boat
and cross the atlantic and you know land
on the eastern shore of
the of the new world is really really
hard
hope you brought a sword because there's
gonna be some wild animals you gotta
figure out your food right when you get
here
so maybe you do the same thing now yeah
i mean look it's not even that buy some
land
in the in the middle of nowhere it's not
gonna be that expensive and alaska pays
you when you live there
i'm pretty sure that would cover your
property taxes if you've got like a
couple acres but that's only going to
help you dip
out if you really want to change the
system and organize i mean you could do
it under the radar like with
encryption and like you know networks
that aren't
seen no i don't even know that you know
how they did it in the old days
the old old old days ancient days like
the philosophers
they wrote their messages in what they
call esoterically
where they would say one thing up here
but the real message was under here for
the people that could parse it and they
were still
able to manage like talking about
philosophy and politics
at the same time as like existing in a
political state
where philosophy often challenges than
that the political state right because
you're talking about politics right in
most of cases
and and this was a style of
communicating that was able to
mask the underlying message so we're
going to have to get better at that
that's for sure
let me just being 280 characters it's
like i'm gonna
sedition i'm gonna rain on the parade of
everybody what parade there's no parade
you're going to rain on my funeral so
there there are people who still are
like no
you know i'm going to reign on the
parade of those who have what little
optimism left oh right okay let's
shove those black holes down there let's
let's just make the rain
it's it's not just rain it's great it's
acid rain
it's acid inhale stuff on fire it's
hailing there's lightning
a lot of friction the wind is kicking up
people are standing there their skin is
peeling
okay did you know that uh
the illegal immigrants in this country
have their have votes represented in the
presidential election yep
i did not i did not know that it's very
simple
the electoral college is comprised of
uh it's it's it's basically however many
states
how many representatives they have they
get an electoral vote
illegal immigrants are counted towards
representation in congress
so when california says sanctuary state
and starts bringing in as many people as
possible
and incentivizing it with free health
care like they did for people under 26
they then say now we have seven million
people
we'll take 10 congressional seats and 10
electoral votes please
and it works that means figure out how
many illegal immigrants are in this
country
now they may not be directly voting but
so long as they live
in california we're not a direct
democracy we do not win the presidency
of the popular vote
so it doesn't matter necessarily if an
individual casts the vote it matters if
the state
chooses who to vote for and if the state
has more congressional seats because
they allow illegal
immigrants into the country well then
they have more more is
of greater likelihood that the
democratic president can win
because california has an obscene amount
of congressional representation
because they inc not necessarily because
of illegal immigration is actually
reading um some different immigration
studies which the left calls like far
right
and they don't say it's actually that
much it's like one extra vote
but that still matters in the context
what i'm talking about you want to talk
about a collapse in the system you want
to talk about
joe biden going after his political
rivals you know donald trump's lawyer
how how long has it been that this
system that
you could be not a citizen and still
influence the presidential election
and so what happens then because of that
simple fact the democratic party is
incentivized to get more congressional
representation right now
trevor noah from the daily show has a
segment where he sang 89 people
89 people in new york didn't fill out
their census come on men and now all of
a sudden we lose a congressional seat
that's how important it is and an
electoral vote
it's not about you know voter fraud or
people voting
it's about congressional representation
and the electoral college
that's what you get when you have more
people this isn't the first time though
that the united states has based their
electoral votes on non-voting
populations right no of course right
yeah
slavery obviously is the very first good
example of that
uh dude i'm feeling it i'm feeling all
that and that's exactly why
when uh donald trump proposed in the
2020 census
to actually ask people who were being
counted if they were citizens
of the united states that the left
freaked out about that
whenever the left freaks out about
something that is perfectly
rational like are we counting citizens
here are we just counting every schlub
that walked across the street
because it determines how many votes we
have in congress and all these things
when they're freaking out about
something that's perfectly rational then
you know it's part of their
their game plan all right i'm gonna do a
180 now
and i'm gonna i'm going to to to be a
rain of sunshine on your horse
the sky is clearing up the acid rain is
going away people are
are now looking up at the sunlight i
don't trust although their acid acid
rain
riddled skin is being hurt by the
sunlight they're still smiling to see it
i'm going back underground now you're
gonna you're gonna love this one ladies
and gentlemen we got this amazing story
check this out
project veritas has an update in their
lawsuit with the new york times
and the new york times is tripping over
themselves
and taking a dump on their own
credibility in a desperate attempt to
stop james o'keefe
is glorious so james put out an update
video
the defense the new york times is going
with is that they have no idea what's
going on
they didn't actually investigate james
o'keefe for his story they didn't talk
to any
any people involved or ask anyone for
comment it was a bunch of opinions
and they they're completely ignorant of
anything that happened in this case this
is their without malice part of the
argument
but this means that james o'keefe has
just taken an
axe to the base of the fake news
narrative tree
in his in in the veritas video they
point out how
after the new york times says this usa
today cites the new york times
saying project veritas is part of
coordinated disinformation
then you get wikipedia and you get
twitter facebook
all running the same story and banning
this based on the on the fact that the
new york times said it was true
and now the new york times has admitted
in no uncertain terms
in a court of law one it was just our
opinion two we didn't actually follow up
on any of this story and three
we honestly have no idea what's going on
anyway that's malicious
yeah well malicious is a reference to
knowing it's false right so what they're
saying is we're
totally clueless about this story so it
can't be malice
maybe not malice um what would you call
it not legal matter when you just like
fire a gun everywhere without looking
and then it hits somebody religion
yeah negligence convincing a depraved
mind negligence was the word i was
looking for negligence is that illegal
can you hit someone on negligence
what i love is that all these news
organizations take the same tact
it's like oh we're not actually
reporting facts we don't actually
investigate stuff we're just talking
we're just speculating it's like
willfulness it's one thing when tucker
carlson
is defending himself in a suit and says
it's an opinion show that no one should
take seriously or whatever
it's another thing when the new york
times runs a fact-based news story in
their
main news section and has to admit to
the court these are not opinion writers
these are news reporters
who published in the news section
opinions that they did not investigate
anyway so they're either malicious or
incompetent
dumb or diabolical all the things that
we've been talking about for
years now coming to the forefront but
guess who's gonna care
guess how much traction that story is
going to get guess how much of an impact
that's going to make in american
people's minds
that the new york times admits that they
don't fact check they don't research
they don't investigate the stories that
they put out as fact
how much influence is that going to have
none
that much guys that much are you got
your neck
are you making a no it's a neck it's a
neck thing it's a neck thing
you see the story of the jeopardy
contestant who did the three-pointer
hand sign because he won three times and
they started
screaming he was a white supremacist
this poor you know what's funny is that
this guy could win jeopardy and still
not understand the context of the
opening
gesture definitely it's like dude you
you you read trivia all day certainly
you read the news story about why you
don't make that
because that's certainly trivial so
project veritas still is
this is good because it is part of the
battle and
veritas is suing twitter as well and cnn
and they're probably going to win
yes and it's going to empower veritas
more
and it at least you know someone is
fighting back and having a good go at it
however regular people watching cnn
won't hear it and the people who already
like veritas will and be like
good but it's a tool for all of you
if you're somebody who is sick and tired
yes you ian know him
no jack jack if you are somebody who has
friends and family
and i know it's difficult because a lot
of people are like my parents my friends
they won't watch the stuff they won't
read the news anyway they don't want to
hear it
it's one more thing we can be like oh
hey look at that the new york times
admits they don't actually fact check
their stories
at the very least you can do this dude
they won't even believe it though you
could
read it to them new york times in the
new york times them saying they don't
they won't even believe it but no no no
no it's all about how you present it
if you go to a family member let's say
you got a joe biden supporting family
member
and you go to them and go biden is awful
you know i'll tell you why i can't
believe you voted for me you argue with
him like man get out of here get i don't
go get out of here but if you walk up to
him you go do you see that crazy thing
that lawsuit or something
the new york times apparently admitted
they don't even fact check their stories
weird huh that's it's all i say it's
neutral that's good
it's just i don't know and then they're
like what does that mean they're like i
don't know i guess i'll subscribe
to usa today or something because yeah
and you don't you don't make it a big
thing you don't tie it to things you
just tell them outright
so you're sitting there you're like do
you hear about that story uh the other
day like i guess
like the new york times got sued and
then they came out and just admitted
that their their news stories have
unverified opinion
they're not fact-checking man that's
crazy i guess
you know i'll probably just you know
take a different paper i guess that's
crazy but you know at the washington
post they used to do fact checking of
the president they stopped doing that
did you hear that
oh yeah some dude joe biden yeah
something to joe buy joe by his present
now we don't need to fact check him
because he's not actually really saying
those things
they just announced that today they just
announced that today because they don't
think it's actually joe biden
no it's whoever's writing his talking
points so therefore they don't need to
fact check the president okay
guys hey george bush went into iraq but
you know what it was based on the
information of other people that they
gave him but that doesn't matter
doesn't matter no one needs to be held
responsible for anything anymore
because uncle joe papa joe he president
now and everything's okay
yeah i love these tweets from the the
establishment lefties who are like
i woke up on sunday and everything was
great because trump didn't tweet and
it's like you open the news and it's
like joe biden bombs
syria or whatever right did he bomb siri
already no he didn't right
no no no no i believe i believe that
they did and i believe
they did yep and there was also uh a a
shot fired at an iranian ship i believe
oh yeah i remember that because i
tweeted that one out i said orange man
orange man made me do it sorry sorry
biden
biden launched an airstrike against
syria one month into his presidency
right
exactly so it's like you know these
people are all cheering and have you
seen the commercial where the woman
she's working at a shop and the the the
flowers in the shop are talking to her
and she's singing and it's like disney
and the puddle goes i'm gonna put lisa
on crutches and then everything turns
back to normal and she goes what
and then the guy's like you know you
gotta get crutches man and it's
you know an insurance commercial or
something it's a good commercial but i
see that it reminds me of like these
these biden people who are now posting
biden sucks
you know biden voters posting their l's
this is twitter account for this
and it's the people who are like during
the election going like yeah
and they're all like singing good
morning star shine or whatever and
holding hands under the rainbow
and then a month then they're like
everything is dark and gloomy and
and awful and there's a there's a dark
filter on the lens that makes you just
feel miserable
you know what's interesting i thought
that being right would make me feel good
no they really really don't feel worse
it makes me
feel worse it's being part of the crowd
that makes you feel good
yes being right when everything's going
so wrong
every step of the way it's like ah if
you have a lot of people with you
agreeing with you and acknowledging that
you're right it helps i have
a hundred and eight thousand now two
people on twitter
agreeing with me largely and it still
doesn't help it makes me feel terrible
being right one of the greatest people
in history
died in poverty they were hated
throughout their lives they were
persecuted they were
like socrates was made to drink poison
he
they weren't accepted but that doesn't
make them wrong
so maybe you're one of those people well
i'm definitely not in poverty so i'm
winning
socrates got you buddy you're doing
better than this so great
i i don't know man it's kind of it's
kind of worrying to me that we've built
a culture
a society of people who are desperate to
just be a part of the crowd i would
think we'd be passionate about no
no no no that's not us we didn't build a
society that does that that's human
nature bro that's human nature
everywhere all across time all across
everything
why because we thrive in small groups
yeah but look at sparta dude those
people were nuts
that's the opposite we don't want to go
that direction either but what i'm
saying like that you can build a society
that's like
i mean they would like what would they
do wouldn't they like test babies
yeah they would get they would kill any
sick babies no but wouldn't they like
hold them under water or something i
don't know
some something ridiculous where it was
like if the baby survived it was strong
enough
warrior keep warrior kids with fights
in the military from age uh either six
or eight to
thirty every every spartan was in the
military i'm not i'm not all about that
they were training but we have the
opposite where it's like you know
you've seen idiocracy right yes those
those those that reproduce the most wins
so it's like you combine idiocracy with
wall-e
where you have all the people just
morbidly obese in hover chairs
and that's what we've been for a long
time we've been a nation of
just life's too good too easy no
conflict no challenge no struggle
and it is it's our own well i'd say it's
our own fault but i wasn't alive and i
think you know we here on the show
are you know trying desperately to get
people to care about the future of this
planet
and and things like that but there are
people of previous generations i guess
it's you know
good men i'm sorry good times make weak
men
weak men make hard times maybe the hard
times are going to make some strong men
in the next generation
things will turn around that american
dream where they're like i'm just going
to get my own little plot of land and
everyone else can screw off and i'll
protect my family and everyone else
goodbye that's
that's not good because what that's done
is created like this subsection of
plutocrats that are like
i'm going to protect myself and let the
rest of society no no no no no no
the number one factor to resist tyranny
is the power to feed and protect
yourself
if you have land and you can feed
yourself that is the
best protector against tyranny there
ever was
that is why rome it was a big deal to
have land and take care of yourself
and as soon as they stopped as soon as
like land owning stopped being as
dispersed as it was
warriors and soldiers couldn't own land
anymore or it stopped becoming a
requirement uh in order to be
a uh in the army land holding got
consolidated by wealthiest aristocrats
and the people didn't have land to take
care of themselves that's the problem
in america if we everybody was
homesteading if everybody could have
their own food
their own energy their own warmth their
own land their own security
well that is a mighty fine resistance to
tyrion you're saying it's like
when the wealthy took away the ability
of the regular people to have
land and survive they became dependent
upon that system yes
so where are you leading me tim i don't
know you know i'm thinking about this
and i'm wondering if
what if what if the workers of the world
united united
i see the world i can't i do
that was too gentle you were just you
were just drawing me in there you're
like what are you doing
no how about this farmers of the world
unite that's
better i'll elaborate no hold on hold on
see i i see they they take that
statement workers of the world unite
and it's become a bad thing because of
the darkness that's that that's behind
it
exploitation but regular working people
agreeing to defend each other from
exploitation and the corrupt political
elites is not a bad thing
no the bad thing is when the corrupt
political elite says hey i'm we're going
to get all the workers to unite now just
do as i'm do do as you're told
or else exactly that's the problem to
clarify the american dream or whatever
of having your own land and protecting
having
and how that's a problem is that i think
that some people just stop
there and that's it and then they don't
care about other people
and and so they they're okay if other
people are suffering like well he
arrested that guy
it's not my problem and the isolationist
mentality that kept us out of world war
ii for instance
so there's more to it yeah you want your
own property and your own
your own food but you have to think
about and care for
others i know it's not like you don't
want to politicize it and make people do
it but we need to do that
what's funny is about when people do
have their own land and their own
sustenance and their own heat and their
own protection
the need to actually engage with and
care about other people and your
interaction with other
it just it decreases right it's that can
it's that connectivity
especially over long-range distances to
bring us all together into this
proximity that we're not accustomed to
this is actually part of the problem and
that's why they want everybody to have
guns
so in a good in the good way right right
right you if you have your property you
don't really
you know have you guys seen them you've
seen the movie the patriot with mel
gibson
yes what an amazing movie yeah but the
british hate it apparently because it
makes them look like villains but
oh the british it was pure propaganda
but but but there's that there's that
scene where
mel gibson's like we're going into town
and they're like oh we're going into
town because you don't
go into town like you live in a farm you
work you do nothing but work going to
town was like a rare thing
before the telephone but so right right
it's like a mail carrier has delivered a
mail and your everyone gathers around
what is it what's the message oh man
because oh
i i've been looking at chickens for six
months give me something to read
but so what happens is back then
everybody needs to be ready and able to
defend themselves
because how if someone starts invading
your your land
how will you get word out to the local
militia to the community
you got to be ready and able to defend
yourself then when conflict starts
word will spread eventually and then
people can start mobilizing but in the
meantime
you need to be able to have to have you
you need to keep and bear arms
i'm gonna agree with ian a little bit on
this one because this is actually
something i've really been thinking
about and i'll explain myself
this is like the underlying idea okay so
this is a problem that i've actually
watched
you can make fun of me i don't care i
don't know i make it for the ian
okay so this is the underlying issue i
think in like the libertarian party and
to some extent in the conservative
movement
is that this idea of the individual is
so much higher
than every other ideal and i understand
how important that is and i fully
respect and appreciate that that's
crucial
but ian is right that we need to have
that community and tim just talked about
that he's like you need to be able to
defend yourself you need to be able to
gang up with other people when it's time
to rise to the occasion and fight the
bad guys that's right a well-regulated
militia exactly like that's a group
you know yeah and by regulated i think
we mean trained and equipped
right functioning function doesn't
necessarily mean trained it just means
functioning functioning
yeah so uh in the patriot i love the end
where i think it's cornwallis he goes
he's like what does he say like are my
eyes deceiving me or is that militia
forming at their center yeah because the
militia
weren't trained they were right but but
they were functional
they were functional they had weapons
they they could follow orders they could
generally cooperate which away but they
were not
trained i gotta say man it's really
funny when you look back at history and
you're like why would anyone fight a war
that way you know what i mean like
marching with drummers
there was a meme on reddit and they were
like someone said i cannot understate
the the absurdity of the fact that
armies had drummers marching into battle
just playing a drum like dude you're
gonna die what are you doing
not careful allocation of resources i
guess that's before radio that's how
they communicated with troops
and the horns and the flags and all that
stuff so they knew where to go
because you couldn't hear someone yell
but the crazy thing is people need to
realize this
man we're all really standing on the
shoulders of giants
the crazy thing is that if you took the
average person
and dropped them like put brought them
back in time a few thousand years
they certainly aren't gonna be building
nuclear fusion reactors or probably even
very complex machines but they know what
a wheel is
they know what a gear is they know how
to make bread
i assure you not good bread but you take
the average person how do you make bread
like i don't know flour water an egg or
something
they'd figure it out really quickly
because they've seen it yeah
whereas thousands of years ago people
would be like what's bread
take a regular person they'll be like
see that stuff mash it up and they'll
mash it up very poorly
mix it with some water and then put it
over a fire and they'll get some crappy
bread
but everyone else would be shocking then
they can be like check out a wheel
there's basic things that we know simply
because we've grown up in a world where
we stand on the shoulders of giants so
when it comes to warfare it seems
obvious to us
what kind of [ __ ] would just march in a
field very slowly and then just stand
there
why weren't they taking cover oh take it
for granted
the transition between like sword based
you know infantry battles and the
rifle-based battles were bad ones look
at what happened in the civil war
civil war we were using old school
techniques of
of like some fronts and like storming at
each other and all that with these guns
and cannons with percussion cap
revolvers
right and and so many people died
so many people died and i think that's
one reason why we didn't get involved in
world war one and suit as soon as the
other countries because we had a very
visceral memory of what it was like to
use stupid-ass old techniques against
modern
weapons and so many people died just
like they did in world war one
france they would they would get out of
the trenches and charge
towards machine guns which is the first
time they'd ever been used in war i mean
the modern machine guns you've seen
gallipoli have you seen the movie
gallipoli with mel gibson when he's like
18.
oh dude you have got to watch that yeah
what's it about uh it's about him in the
australian infantry and they're in
turkey it's
near the end of world war one and it's
about him
as a courier trying to stop i don't want
to ruin it
trying to stop a rush coming out of the
trench into the oh it's like
1917. yeah it's like time have you seen
have you seen it have you seen that
that movie's awesome amazing the whole
movie is
in the style of a single shot no breaks
and it follows
yeah two to infantrymen like going it
through
it's world war one yeah world war one
and it's it's it's amazing
yeah so the camera does have cuts they
do things where like it goes past a tree
but the time is it's real time oh
fascinating the movie is amazing and
it's a similar story so in that regard
the fact that we're fighting our
conflicts now with china
and internally in a fourth or fifth
generation warfare
situation with economics information
morality
emotions all these kind of things rather
than just force on force
there's a there's a little bit of
evolution there it reminds me of that
old star trek
right where they're just like we're at
war with this planet
and uh okay we've decided there will be
this much calc you know this much
casualties
in this war and they just send people
off to their little death camps and
stuff
yeah i'm pretty sure with star trek but
they just like calculated the casualties
and everybody had to like suffer
and some people just walked off and they
didn't actually fight the wars they just
calculated the wars
i don't remember that which series was
it oh like original original series yeah
okay maybe
yeah yeah i think someone in the chat
will bring that up for sure
it reminds me more sorry a better
analogy i think is uh zapp brannigan in
futurama
when he said that he he defeated the
killbots by realizing they had a preset
kill limit
so he just sent wave after wave of his
own men until that limit was reached and
then they stopped fighting oh yeah sort
of like sherman
there you go
brutal what were you going to say bro
we're all looking at you
we've always used i don't know if
there's an end to this but there's we've
always used those techniques that we
have now that
we call it fifth dimensional war or
whatever there's like generational yeah
the love of
you know fighting for this dimensional
war yeah traveling through time and
space and alternate dimensions not going
to feel good
jack besovic's next book false flags
and getting people to fight for
something that did wasn't real you know
was it was an ancient
an ancient thing because if you can as
long as you can frenzy people into
wanting to do it that's really the end
well you know what was even easier was
like let's just go get rich y'all
that was distracting wealth yeah
conquests
the vikings that's what dude they just
went and invaded england just to get
gold
chalices all right now now let's let's
let's let's get back on track for a
second oh right giuliani
well no wait we're talking about we
haven't talked about we
we just you know we're talking about
veritas and the victory and i want to
keep
raining down sunshine on people because
please it started really dark i mean the
julian honestly it's freaky feels good
ladies and gentlemen we've got a secret
weapon oh you ready for this ultimate
secret weapon i'm ready it is the return
of magareli's i'm kidding
but donald trump is planning uh he may
hold
manga rallies beginning in may according
to a report
he may the trump brothers are going to
come back and you know i jokingly say
it's a secret weapon
but it is going to start kicking things
back
up getting people back in in focus
maybe not uh you know there's there are
some bad people i guess but
the general idea is getting people to
center around something
probably something better than i don't
know just
pessimism and black pills yeah i don't
man i hate trashing trump because he's
not a horrible human but i just
i don't like that he's the guy i mean
yep that's right he's got money he's got
many fatal flaws
many one of them is this desperate need
to be liked
yeah has to be liked and as darren b
very astutely pointed out on our last
friday sessions check it out youtube.com
forward slash jack murphy live
he was an insider trump insider i also
interviewed amanda milius at the same
time and
also a trump insider and they both were
very honest
and very open and candid about the flaws
of the trump administration
from the perspective of true maga
believers
who were appointed by the president
right
so this is an honest assessment as
you're going to get and one of the
things that they drilled down on was the
fact that
trump needed to be liked and what that
translated into
was him saying things like oh there's no
there's everybody loves us on campus oh
there's no dis there's no
there's no conflicts in the street oh
everybody everything's great
everything's great about this everybody
loves stocks
right but at the same time there was
actually violence you couldn't wear a
maga hat on campus there was actually
violence at the rallies there was
actually people
you know attacking other people for
supporting trump and so his
desire don't get excited i truly am not
excited
about that i i wish i were i wish there
was a 3.0 person who was like
ready to beat the trump that we really
need now
uh but uh that person hasn't seemed to
materialize just yet
and trump desantis you know i i just
don't i i've watched him in florida
i don't know too terribly much about him
the people of florida may not vote for
him as president because they want him
to stay
as governor you never know crazy things
have happened trump had that star power
he was a famous famous business mogul
like who it'd be like mark cuban elon
musk like who's a
zuckerberg you know some crazy not him
obviously
trump before he was president more
famous than all three of those guys
three of those guys are now
yeah i wish so famous i wish zuckerberg
would have run on the democratic ticket
that'd be cool in 2020 you know why
because then he would well actually i
don't know if he would have won but it
would have been hilarious
to see him trying to it would have been
the worst possible thing for the people
of this planet but it would have been
hilarious to have like
you know zuckerberg is like a
combination of data from star trek and
the joker he looks like data
right he really looks like that so it
does oh so like
like lore basically well no no no no
in star trek laura is data's brother
he's another but he's like
megalomaniacal yeah that that that
doesn't really work no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no like
they did a good twin bad twin shtick
with data in his android brother well
the original
uh i think lore was first synthetic
humanoid
was with emotions and he became
sociopathic
so then data was created without
emotions and had to like learn or
whatever
but no no it's not a fair comparison it
would actually be like you know data
wasn't
was a good person you know struggling
and trying to learn how to become human
you you take that element of the very
analytical data driven
and combine it with the joker and you
get mark zuckerberg
it would have been a hilarious
presidency i've been awesome but but
he's
more powerful now right so he didn't
want to do it yeah
and that's a sad statement when we find
out that the corporations are more
powerful than the presidency of the
united states
that's a problem you know libertarians
i've been laughing all day so uh
you may you might not know this but uh i
actually got more heavily involved
well let me let me i got heavily
involved in politics through just
general activism i was younger in music
and i worked for non-profits but there
was a period where i started hanging out
at hackerspaces in like 2010
2011. so i became friends with a lot of
very prominent hackers
in these in these spaces hackerspaces
and
at the time anonymous was really big the
hacker
you know collective online and a couple
other groups like telecomics
some of these individuals stayed true to
their
uh data love and libertarian principles
of rejecting authoritarianism
but something really interesting
happened there's a hacker convention
called defcon
which is a very prominent sort of the
biggest hacker convention they also have
black cat which is very corporate
and we were watching like my friends
some of these very prominent well-known
famous hackers
the woke infestation and activists
started coming to the hacker conferences
people who are not hackers at all
who didn't understand the culture didn't
understand the symbols didn't understand
what it like literally anything about
agriculture but they liked the activism
that they saw from hackers so they
started coming in some of these people
at the time were very very
anti-intelligence agency
i mean there were people screaming and
ranting about
spying and all that stuff and something
really interesting happened i think it
was
a few years ago a four one guy
was speaking at defcon and made a
statement where he was supporting
law enforcement and the audience started
clapping and cheering and he was like
wow
never thought i would give a speech at
def con and have people cheer for the
federal government
and they were cheering because he was
speaking about russian interference and
things like that
my favorite thing all day i've been just
laughing slapping my knee
are some of these hacktivist antifa
people that i know
cheering on the fbi right now and so
i've been commenting on their pages i'm
like i am so glad to see you've been
de-radicalized and you're on board with
the federal government
you know i was really worried because
you were very anti were very extremist
under government when i knew you
to see you now fully on board with
authority and the liberal
you know the liberal uh you know
liberals running the government
it's it's it's a good thing and all of a
sudden their brains like
oh you broke them did it work
well they're rebooting we'll find out
right right now they'll come back with
something else it won't break
there's no way to shake people free even
with logic in their own behavior held up
to them with a mirror one inch from
their face
it's like one out of ten it takes trauma
it takes serious trauma where you're
where you finally
have to admit that your mental model of
the world is not leading you into
productive outcomes
i got it i got it i got an idea uh-oh
here's what you got to do all right
acid hail no no go to your go to your
friends and family right
the ones that you know are the ones that
are still talking to me yeah the ones
like
i'd be like do you guys want to go see
this this this band play
you want to go see a band and then when
they're like oh sure like
we're gonna we're gonna go out and see
this big show it's gonna be fantastic
it's gonna be this famous uh you know
saxophonist or something
and then you bring them to a mike rally
and then you pull up in the parking lot
you walk up they're like why is it
bringing monkey hats like oh i don't
know
and then you get them in and then
they're standing there like what's going
on and that's when trump comes out
and then they're going to be like what's
that but then they're going to see it's
a bunch of regular people and everyone's
going to be smiling there's going to be
babies and then people can be shaking
hands and donald trump's gonna be
you know i'm kidding by the way don't
really do that oh i was like
i was like signing people up in my head
visioning in my mind what was gonna
happen when he started
when he starts going lock her up lock
her up
well i don't think he'll do that now
right especially because giuliani's
gonna be in jail
we just we just watched earlier the curb
your enthusiasm where he gets the idea
where the maga hat yeah it's like
talking so good because he has a he has
to have a meeting larry dave has
a meeting with a guy doesn't like yeah
so he gets the idea to wear a maga hat
and the guy is like sitting in the
restaurant and he's like uh i i gotta go
and i don't want to be here so then my
favorite bit is when he's driving
and he cuts off the biker and the biker
is like yelling at him like ah
so he pulls over and then he puts the
hat on and then the biker goes just be
more careful next time and then she
leaves
that was a great show that was good it's
a good show he he is uh
id unchecked right like just behaving
with no regard for anyone else about
anything his fields ofs are fallow
as f
[Laughter]
do you think i mean this is kind of an
obvious thing when we talk about the
giuliani thing we didn't even mention
the uh
hunter biden email laptop right that
giuliani basically spearheaded and
popularized as best as he could
makes me think that it's a political
position but i still don't know any of
the evidence maybe he did something
wrong
dude we sit here and we look at these
facts and we're like we are so right
we're so right about everything the
insurgents
bull crap the retribution bull crap the
the the the like stepping on the
constitution all these things
all the election stuff we're like [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] we are we are
so comfortable in our position what do
you mean
i just i mean i'm open to challenges and
critique but like i'm pretty sure that
the way we see the world
is accurate but there's there's another
group of four sitting around right now
somewhere doing a podcast right now
looking at the same fact pattern and
saying a narrative completely opposite
180 of what we're saying and they feel
as secure as we do that they're right
sure
this is the problem there's a podcast
it's called like things you should know
or something you've ever heard of it
nope have you heard of that
no stuff you should know young
genociders or something no no
no no it's just like some dude sitting
around but i i listened to one of these
episodes and
again i could be wrong by the name of
the podcast but they were talking about
like climate change and then one of the
guys is like
dude like i mean fossil fuels are going
to run out anyway we need to start doing
research and the other guy goes
like yeah dude like there's never going
to be dinosaurs you know what i mean
and the guy's like right like fossil
fuels are dinosaurs and we're not going
to have more dinosaurs and then the
guy's like
could you imagine if they like made a
jurassic park thing to like make more
dinosaurs we can get more oil and i was
like
what the these what is this it's a top
podcast
first of all we already synthesized
petroleum with algae
it's not dinosaurs wow lots of ways blue
crude there's lots of ways to make oil
nowadays
yes yeah pressure plastic with no oxygen
well really convert it back into
converting it back so i i i was like
these these people
they're people who genuinely think
petroleum is dinosaurs oh my
it's like dude it's it's not i think i
think it's mostly algae anyway
it's just it's just organic matter
decomposed for the most part i believe
but regardless it's like i just i was
reading an article like the week before
about
a breakthrough in synthesized petroleum
it's not really energy efficient to do
it's energy efficient for us to take it
out of the ground because it's already
been created
and maybe there's you know other things
we can do but there are people
when they sit around in their pockets
they talk about stuff yeah they're dumb
they're dumb they really are dumb so no
there is no one else that's looking at
the facts like we are we should be
as deservedly assured in our positions
as we are in ours
it's it's it's listen when i when i talk
to him are we the dummies
no no no no i'll tell you this
we may not be correct very good we may
not be correct
it may be that we only see the surface
layer
of the giuliani fbi thing and below the
surface it could be man it could be nuts
for all we know aliens are involved i
have no idea top secret
i mean true it was my first reaction to
be like look
the fbi department of justice a judge
signed off on a warrant
like we have a system in place to make
sure that nothing frivolous like this
happens so
my first instinct is to be like man that
giuliani done
effed up somehow but but what if
but aliens yes are holding our
government hostage
true and told the judge he had to do it
vampire aliens vampire aliens
yeah but who can actually see themselves
in mirrors yes yeah
and they can teleport right yeah the
point i'm making is i'm a gorilla
in in yeah i am the reality though is
that there's confidential stuff we don't
know about
definitely i'm not saying it's justified
i'm not saying i know what the story is
it could very well be
that like uh mission impossible like
team
stole the vial of you know the the jet
fr
stole the vial of fuel from the genesis
device and rudy giuliani
has a laptop with the file on it doesn't
realize it i don't know i'm just saying
there's a lot of stuff we don't know so
we're sitting here as
informed as informed as we can be we may
be wrong about all of this stuff for all
we know
russia is secretly at war with you know
some country and there's just a whole
bunch of stuff we don't know what's
going on
but i will tell you when i listen to
these other shows
i can immediately say they never read
that story they never read that story
they don't know about this conflict they
don't know about that conflict
you look at the stuff with giuliani
right now i did a segment on it uh uh
for my main channel
do you know what the giuliani stuff is
really about is it it said that he
was advocating on ukraine syria well
it's about the pipeline
what's going on with stream two so so
let me let me tell you my thoughts
do you think that joe biden got a
prosecutor fired to cover up for his son
who was being
who's facing potential corruption
investigation sounds plausible to me
what what i think the issue for a lot of
people is
if that's all you know it sounds like
that's what joe biden did
however i think there's a more obvious
reason hunter biden was on the board of
barisma
gazprom has controls a large portion of
the natural gas coming into
the european union that's through
ukraine and is controlled by russia
so u.s and western interests need energy
companies
loyal to the west not russia and so
there's been a series of conflicts one
the euro maiden protest the separatist
movement
nato and its allies the west the united
states want control of nato
want control of ukraine so that they can
control the flow of natural gas into
europe through these pipelines
russia wants ukraine in the trade
federation separatist
fights break out so the u.s goes to
syria and says
maybe we can off offset this monopoly by
building the turkey pipeline
my personal opinion and i'm lacking a
ton of information
is that joe biden's intervention
in the investigation into charisma of
which there was an investigation
according to matt taibi
was to protect western interests not
because the prosecutor was corrupt
the prosecutor likely was loyal to the
country of ukraine not the united states
and near european union and not
necessarily to russia
but an investigation into barisma was
bad for the u.s so biden intervenes
and his son was there incidentally
because the u.s positioned key figures
who are loyal to this country
what's a guarantee you want someone go
to the country you put a c a former cia
director which they did
and the son of the sitting vice
president now you know this company will
always have your back
and you don't got to worry about an
assad saying nam with russia that makes
more sense
rudy giuliani starts digging up
information into what's going on
and maybe could it because i'm saying
there's so much i don't know underneath
the surface
but maybe what was happening was that
individuals in ukraine
were giving information to giuliani and
trump allies
that would have shown the u.s was
meddling in the national affairs of
ukraine
for u.s and european interests not
ukrainian interests and if the ukrainian
people find out about that
they will reject nato because they don't
want to live under a boot ever again
yes my opinion i don't know if it's true
or not because i don't have access to
confidential information
there's probably a bunch of other
stories i haven't seen but it is a long
and complicated story
no that seems to make sense also tim by
the way
you what an encyclopedia of information
do you read and retain more than most
people i've ever met
in my whole life very impressive so when
we talk about these lefty podcast people
who are like
dude was not
was not a good he was corrupt and then
it's like did you read met taib's piece
on this
no why didn't you i don't know it
existed all right well that's a good
excuse i suppose i can't blame someone
for not
knowing because i don't know things that
you know their things exist i don't know
about
but matt man did he did he nail this
when he did his investigation and he
said
there was like a dozen active
investigations against barisma and this
corrupt
this corrupt guy who flees the country
and so to say that there was no
investigation you know you know i'm
gonna say this
guys intelligence bros who are watching
this
show i'm sorry i just think you're bad
at what you do now
hold on hold on you're probably really
good at what you do by your standards
and by relative standards
but i just think i can do a better job
like if you wanted to actually convince
people of u.s interests and like why
it's important to have more energy
flowing into the european union
particularly because
the european union one of its goals is
to compete against china
because they needed european countries
unified i mean maybe that's the message
you should have rolled with
instead of it's all a lie trust the
mainstream media and then when people
catch them in lies what do you do
man these people have no it's like being
honest is actually
the best way to go about it insulting
the intelligence of people with garbage
stories and banning someone's name from
youtube
doesn't solve the problem it makes it
worse i kind of feel like
the intelligence agencies were handed
off to a bunch of young kids
the next generation of deep state who
are like i don't know how to run this
thing
and now it's all falling apart that
happens every generation i think
though i've seen it happen especially in
wall street and finance where like the
younger guys
they figure out new investment
strategies and new asset classes and
they
go all crazy and the risk management
folks and the senior partners have no
idea what they're doing
that's where you can make some real
money and in the intelligence
industry you know i mean look it's i
think it's pretty much like that
in all in all industries but what i'm
struck by here especially
is how much of the
of the surface water of our foreign
policy and economic policy and politics
is all subterfuge the real things are
happening below their title forces
and in this case it's about energy right
and the whole syrian no-fly zone from
2016 clinton proposition
uh to the you know people being mad at
trump for wanting to calm down
tensions in syria and calm down tensions
with
all this is based around pipelines it's
all based around energy and it's a much
deeper structural thing that has nothing
to do with some of the surface stuff
that we get distracted by
and that's how i know we're on the right
side
is because the the left they want a
circumstance in which the people of the
european union have less access to
energy
and that the people of ukraine don't
have sovereign decision over there
right over their country and and and our
side wants
more energy into the european union and
for the ukrainian people to decide their
sovereignty well no no i think the the
establishment wants more energy into the
european union
but they don't care about you kind well
no they
they want um i don't know
again there's more details that we need
and i am certainly not an expert on this
subject
let me give you a hypothetical all right
donald trump i'm much better with those
donald trump comes into office and
immediately michael flynn says china's a
bigger threat
intelligence agencies then say we know
china is a bigger threat but don't say
it out loud because we are actively
building up our resistance the european
union was formed partly
to to create a competitive economic
block that can compete against the
growth of china
and we need and russia's in the way
russia's actually in many ways hates
china but also works with them
we need to get more energy into the
european union trump comes trump comes
in and says i don't care about this
ukraine stuff i don't care about the
serious stuff
america first all the way and then you
have these intelligence agencies saying
the first thing we have to do to grow
and be competitive
is have more energy into europe to grow
european influence
not chinese or russian influence i know
russia is partly in europe
then you get trump pulling out of syria
which means over the past four years
trump was stopping the establishment
plan
to get more more energy into the
european union
and to weaken russia which in turn would
weaken china
trump went straight for the throat with
china and then got all these peace
agreements
which made it even harder for the u.s to
operate in the middle east to maintain
control over the region
the u.s isn't there because there's you
know terror or whatever
and the fact this con conflict between
these countries is good for the us
because we'd be like oh no we we have to
be there
we have to send all these bombs to to
these different countries egypt needs
our military aid
trump bringing about peace well now the
u.s is like
what's our justification to the american
people and european people in australia
or whatever our allies
what's the justification for being in a
country when trump brings peace
justification now is we need to bring
transgenderism to the women of
afghanistan pakistan
pakistan pakistan it was like what was
it ten million dollars so so listen i
say it's hypothetical
and the reason why after knowing like
after researching the things that i've
researched and seeing this
you know talking to the journalists and
reading the stories the reason why i
don't trust the establishment
is because they lie all the time and
don't deserve trust
so i'm not going to give them the
benefit of the doubt and assume
they have our best interests i'm going
to assume that cronies within the u.s
government took the job at barisma
because they found a path to making a
ton of money for themselves
not because they actually cared about
the european union and hunter biden took
the job because yeah they needed someone
loyal to the u.s
but they were gonna get money for doing
it
you got a bunch of people who work in
government who swap between these big
energy companies and these military
industrial
complex companies and they make money
for themselves and they operate under
the guise of it's all for the betterment
of the country and when it's not it's
for the betterment of
themselves i would defer to they're more
likely trying to enrich themselves
and using national interests as a cover
they said joe biden's intervention and
ukraine was
in the national interest yeah sure but
what do you think joe biden got out of
it
his kid was getting what like 83 grand
per month
for what securing western interests in
ukraine
i wonder what the ukrainian people would
feel what they would do
if that was public knowledge i'd imagine
it'd be very very bad for nato he's also
kind of
vocally said he wants to get off oil so
for him to
put his son on the board of an oil
company to run a pipeline for oil
and net something we're going to shut
down keystone xl and then build
pipelines in europe and syria
and my son will well it is a natural gas
pipeline to be fair methane
oh it's a mix of gases energy
independence for thee but not for me
apparently earlier you said that you
felt like we were on the right side
that makes me nervous that even people
like you
as brilliant as you are think of
yourself divided into
a side that there are sides that we're
divided against each other
i hate to think like that we are very
clearly divided against each other on
one hand we've got people that believe
in personal accountability and
individual liberty on the other hand we
got people that don't that's a very
big difference bro but i'll tell you the
important thing here is we we don't
we don't need these pipelines you know
joe biden doesn't need the pipelines
we don't need keystone xl either we
don't need syria if we just hooked up
a a a turbine to the graves of the
founding fathers
spinning in their grave at such high
speed it would generate
free and clean energy for a long time
look it's a very powerful notion if you
consider and reflect upon this statement
which i believe to be very true the
founding fathers would lose their mind
if they understood
exactly what we were enduring today and
what would the founding fathers do today
well they
probably are we are we living
up to the sacrifices made by the
founding fathers
and if not why not because they were a
bunch of white supremacist land owners
who just didn't want to pay taxes
and uh is that the narrative they paid
taxes to
themselves they pay taxes locally they
were happy to do that
they paid tariffs and such they just
didn't want
a the parliament and i learned this
actually recently
taxes to the king were seen as a gift
offered by the people
the parliament the house of commons
decided we're going to
offer a gift to the king well the house
of commons was deciding that these
people over here in america needed to
offer a gift to the king
but there was no one representing them
to make that gift that was the basic
reason that they objected to the stamp
and the sugar tax in particular
what would they do now what would they
do now
and then you think well we're kind of
gross
we almost don't deserve what they've
given us
if the founding fathers were alive today
with the same ideology and the same you
know
complaints right now at this moment in
their lives
they would be probably just reading a
book in their cell
you know waiting for exercise hour
in solitary because the surveillance
state would have caught him a long time
ago and locked him up
yeah thomas jefferson might be a rock
star this didn't exist in the 1700s
mass media didn't exist so with this
technology what would they have done ben
franklin was an inventor
you know he'd probably be a technology
guy maybe running a social network or
something or
what's what's the modern equivalent of
putting a key on a kite getting struck
by lightning
launching rockets into space and trying
to get more land to back on a platform
yeah
what if like elon musk just came out one
day with like an extremely profound
philosophical statement on you know
liberty justice and government
like besides like can't get it up
besides like
if i hope there's a scandal about me
it's called elon gate yes
hilarious but you know what would be an
interesting thing would be trying to map
the founding fathers onto
modern day figures this is this is who
ben franklin would be today that's who
george washington would be today
yeah george washington clearly would be
joe biden just
strong strong leadership silver tongue
president
president tall charming did you know
george washington was a failed military
leader can you explain up until this
revolutionary how so
because he he took expeditions out into
the countryside against the indians and
out into the you know pushing boundaries
to the west and
he was never very successful he set out
to like make his name and just
never really did it never really in fact
in fact
he got rejected for being a general in
the british army and some argue
that is the reason why the united states
exists because he had a chip on his
shoulder because he didn't get promoted
to be a general in the british army
because he sucked
as a british officer that he won and
then he won
but then again it begs the question or
raises the question
who maybe someone else could have one
maybe the structural forces
the french one the french destroyed the
brit british colonies
but liberated them thank you francis yes
thank you frank i i don't think it's
fair to say the french won
they certainly intervened but it was
there was already war going on
in you know in europe between britain
and france so it was just
in their interests but it was initiated
by americans fought by americans and
aided by
german mercenaries as well yeah so
actually no no no no the germans were on
the other side
right i let that go earlier by the way
washington crossed the river to kill the
hessians because they were drunk on
christmas
right i'm sure there's a bunch of super
chats for correcting me on that point
because i wasn't
tim you ignorant [ __ ] and after that
whole bit i did about how smart i was
and how
you know it's perfect that's why i say
there's things i don't know because
it's not about if you and if you talk
three hours or four hours every day
we're definitely gonna find out what's
going on you know
but you know i just realized too because
you ever watched liberty's kids no what
is that
you've never seen liberty's kids for a
guy that works as much as you do bro you
certainly consume a flavor
this is a show from like a long time ago
where it's like so i guess some kids
i don't know if they go back in time or
something slide earth
no it's a cartoon where uh these kids
are like
learning about the revolution and
founding fathers and stuff
and i remember an episode where they're
like oh no the hessians are coming or
something so yeah they were on the other
side they were on it but yeah it was it
was a combination of
of conflict between different factions
right how about we read super chat super
chat
we have a we have a very serious problem
what's that tell me
we need people to smash the like button
smashing however
we are down in views you know why i do
you know why
wait today in this particular right now
that's right oh my god jack
it's your fault it could be that joe
biden is addressing the nation in his
first joint congressional address
all right all right that's it that's how
you darn it yeah and not only that
stephen crowder is doing a live stream
of it so i just watched them stephen
stephen who steven kind of
anyway the point is without our legions
of loyal fans
to smash the like button i don't know
what we'll do and i am i am i am
heartbroken they have abandoned us for
joe biden
i'm actually kidding i i do think it's a
good thing you know people want to check
out what he's going to say and
normally we actually take breaks when
like trump would speak
or if like there's going to be a big
event but
i think the last time joe biden spoke he
got like only a couple thousand people
on his live stream and i was like i'm
not gonna
yeah not gonna shut the show down
because joe biden's gonna mumble
something incoherently it's not gonna
happen
so smash the like button smash it go to
timcast.com click that little members
only button
sign up go to the members area we're
going to have a bonus brutal
members only segment coming up should be
live about 11 00 p.m or so and we're
going to talk about some very serious
serious stuff
maybe get some trouble but it'll be on
over at timcast.com and i got great news
we are in rapid development on the site
in about a month and a half or so we're
gonna have a completely again once again
updated because we've been building it
and
growing it we are getting stripe
integration for those that aren't fans
of paypal there'll be more payment
options
and we're going to be bringing on a news
uh news team doing articles
it's gonna be a whole lot of fun let's
read some super chats and thank you all
for your smashing of the like button
showing that we are better than joe
biden that's right
all right i can't read your name but
here's the first super chat i love the
content i'm a ski
bum in utah and i thought liberty was
dying but when i discovered your show it
gave me hope that liberalism in the
classical sense will rise again
and that's why you should share the show
with your friends if you like it because
we
live or die based on your good graces
it's like that simpsons halloween
special where
the advertisements come to life and then
they're like how do you kill an
advertisement don't look at it and then
they'll turn around but homer can't
cause a guy's got a doughnut
and then when he turns around they
finally all like freeze and like lose
their life
same thing for us if people stop looking
then we just freeze in place
so maybe we should offer donuts to
people yeah i'm into it
that's not very keto friendly yeah
that's true that's fair
keto friendly good point no they have
keto donuts we got this really great
keto bread once
it was like fillium husk or something
like mushroom bread or something like
that
it's good cilium is what it's called
yeah psyllium
like mushroom fiber i don't think it's
mushroom oh but yeah i'll look it up
where i'll do my recipe it's like a
sponge
all right let's see what we got here
joel jamal says monday australian mp
craig kelly banned on facebook tuesday
craig kelly proposes legislation like in
florida to protect online speech
wednesday
craig kelly loses parliamentary facebook
page instagram page and link tree
account
collusion yup
it's the name of the game man big deck
mark zuckerberg is your boss
i'll fight you naked says i wrote a
piece on medium called letter to a woke
heart
i send this out so conservatives and
centrists can use it to de-program
left-wing friends
who are not totally infected you know
what i found
if you hadn't if you know any of those
people my
a lot of my friends who post these
things on facebook when i talk to them
privately
they're very timidly saying a lot of the
woke talking points
almost like they don't really believe it
and then when i
shut it down they stop so it's like the
establishment talking points it really
does feel as a lot of people who are
experiencing cognitive dissonance where
in their hearts they're like i don't
like this
but they think everyone else is is you
know woke so they have to say it
i wish i had hope about that i have a
cousin
who's married and they have a few kids
and i i love them
i put a lot of effort into making making
sure we had a relationship that we saw
each other's children that we stayed in
touch with each other
and one day we're talking about feminism
and i'm like yeah that's not how it
works anymore
like explaining to her how feminism had
evolved
she was so stuck in second wave mindset
that now they
they literally have like disowned us as
family members because she can't accept
the fact that feminism isn't even what
she thinks it is anymore
and she thinks because i'm an
anti-feminism and i'm an anti-woman
which isn't the case
obviously well that's why i just you got
you got to make sure you're speaking
very uh you got to understand the
semantics
i think as i think i understand
semantics well don't say
to a second wave feminist you're
anti-feminist to a second wave feminist
you say i completely agree with you and
and your feminism 100 percent i i will
take that unto advisement i'm pretty
sure i tried all those techniques and
tactics and it's just still still a
shame that uh
politics like this especially confusion
but about politics get in the way of
personal relationships this is why the
first thing i ask my friends who are
entering the workspace
is do you believe in dr king's dream
yeah and then when they say yes
and one day my four little children will
be judged based on the content of their
character not the color of their skin
they go right
and then i say oh okay so how do you
feel about the democrats voting against
stopping asian discrimination
and then they're like uh democrats good
democrats good you bad i'm out that was
really funny ted cruz but that amendment
like
he went he proposed an amendment to the
to the you know that was it hate crime
bill or whatever
where it's like you can't discriminate
against asians in universities
and the democrats were like nah nah we
should be allowed to do that so much for
stop asian hate i guess
huh it's insane all right dragon noodle
soup gaming says hey jack yeah
i caught your segment on honey badger
radio a long time ago good stuff oh
thank you
tim you should have brian martinez on
jack and sydney watson have both been on
the show and aiden paladin
is a part of their group that would be
cool
good stuff good show like that guy
he did a reaction video to one of the
times i was on here
and it was quality so i stumbled across
it because i might name search myself
every once in a while
just occasionally turk longwell says
thanks tim
nice opening monologue now i'm sad yet
angry
now more angry i believe veterans of any
age will become the leaders of us
critical thinkers perhaps where's our
cincinnatus
that's what we need simply gray says how
long is that
water bottle been sitting next to you
this water bottle has been sitting next
to me for tonight because i grabbed it
from the fridge
right over there which is full of the
same water bottles and i have a water
bottle every night
it's the same one but this one's
different this is the ramune
ramune japanese premium carbonated soft
drink
you ever see the fun marble drink with
the marbles in the bottle we love them
you could say a lot of things about the
tim cass crew but you can't say that
they don't provide
a wide array of high quality beverages
at every phase and stage of the property
from bottled water to fancy sugary sodas
to coconut water to mct
bio trust this thing keto to
japanese scotch 12-year age scotch that
i had volcanic water
the carbonated volcanic water there's
all this volcanic water you can order
from
specific volcanoes around earth that's
different minerals
i want to drink which volcano would you
like to drink from volcano
volcano blood is it so hot some not
anymore this is important but it's
important
some people who come here are really
worked up and like anxious and like high
strung
and for that we have booze some people
who come are nervous and
and and you know really down and for
that we have energy drinks
and so you really got to know and so so
what i do is when i get here i smash a
couple of espresso
drinks a sugar-free red bull and about
four ounces of japanese whiskey
and bro i'm golden and then you're just
leveling your bag i'm just right back
where i started
all for the drive later all right neil
sawyer says
hey tim just wanted to plug your newest
channel cast castle
it seems like it's going to be great but
speaking of greatness michael knowles
knew oh
michael knull's new book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
is available for pre-order someone
tweeted to michael knowles they were
like
so you know one of your guys got tim to
read a super chat that turned into a
promo for his book and
but he he didn't he uh he he read he
didn't notice before it was too late and
it was funny and michael tweeted about
it i love it that's great but uh we do
have a new channel called cast castle
we have only two videos up but uh we're
just gonna start i've been talking about
doing the vlog and i'm like we just
gotta film and just start doing it
and uh plan activities dude the rc cars
flew through the air very very far we
launched some uh rc cars at like 50
miles an hour over the garage
off the ramp just just it was pretty
flipping through the air
shoot them no you can't shoot bullets up
you can't oh is there a certain degree
that you can't raise your your your
barrel passed your backstop
oh yeah no backstop up there dawg
no it's going to come down somewhere
true that nah uh
even when you live in the middle of
nowhere there's still things and people
you got to know where that's going
true granted there's some places where
you can live where it's probably
like if you're on like a an island
somewhere
and you're like nothing but water around
for days
but uh typically into your back stops
into backstops no no
randomly up in the air well how do you
how do you hunt birds then
bird shot yeah i suppose yeah little
pellets
so do we have video of the rc cars oh
yeah it's a vlog
cast castle that's right there you go
cast castle cass castle
yeah so it's all season youtube.com cast
castle
and uh we might get the garage redone
yeah the one with the skatepark in it
yeah yeah so like
uh getting the roof fixed so that
there's more space and
cleaning it and then i'm i'm i don't
know how much it'll cost because you
know pole bars aren't that expensive but
even putting a deck up top
so we can do shows and have like a vip
section like a hanger
maybe i mean they're they're they're not
that expensive to build these these
it's literally just like sheep sheet
metal up against the wood beam it's it's
just the labor you're paying for but
let's do it summer's coming now's the
time to plan
yes that's right that's right and we got
probably i think um
three million dead stink bugs you know
just along the line here no no in the
there's there's a part with insulation
and there's just all stink bugs yeah
because they're just
they it's it's it's like the manhattan
of stinkbug city you know
beautiful so pumped
all right let's see
free men die free says libertarians have
always had the solution
massively decentralized or even abolish
it entirely
liberty or death man
the price of liberty is blood
so i'm told ask dummy says one thank you
all too
second sc macro pick internet attention
addiction
lulling us into post-truth era where
liars can easily fool masses with
algorithms
woke eyes three why no mention of 99.997
rate in young people with jre vid today
honest question fear of censorship oh so
did you see
joe rogan's getting you know yeah what's
up with that
i i just joe rogan came out and he made
a statement about
uh young people if people if young per a
young person asked him to get a vaccine
vaccinated he'd say if you're young and
healthy
you know you don't need to do it or
whatever then fauci comes out he's wrong
and i'm like
listen i'm not gonna my i don't want to
do a video talking about
cdc guidelines or anything like that
because you got to talk to your doctor
you know what i mean like i don't fault
joe for having a passive conversation
and giving his opinion
but we i guess we're in the era now
where you know a comedian with a
massively influential podcast with great
power comes great responsibility
and i'm just like the fauci's the guy
who came out was and told everyone not
to wear masks early on
now he's the guy telling people to wear
two masks he should have i'm not i'm not
gonna take my opinions from a tv doctor
or from a podcast comedian i'm just
gonna talk to my doctor
you know i i said this before like i go
to my doctor and like they'll give you
some word you've never heard of
prozamidol and you're like i don't know
you know you just if you don't trust
your doctor i don't know what to tell
you man
but uh not an issue uh uh we
we talk about the survival rate for
covid here quite a bit i don't know it
just wasn't an issue for me for the most
part
so i wish that you could just say trust
your doctor
but i have found that a lot of doctors
are really dumb
they don't know about nutritional
information they don't know about diet
and exercise they don't know about all
kinds of stuff and they don't
they're not incentivized to give you the
advice that'll keep you healthy they're
incentivized to keep you in their
practice
the problem i suppose is you need to
find a doctor you trust
you go to a doctor like you hire a
plumber and just be like so look
you probably go on angie's list or
whatever look for a good review before
you hire the plumber yeah you bring the
plumber out and you're like yeah so we
got a problem we got a clog
in the toilet and it'll be like where
it's like i don't know in the pipe
somewhere there are pipes in a toilet
you bet okay this guy's not a plumber
you know what i mean you go to a doctor
and you ask them questions you can't
answer maybe you just find a doctor
that you find you know credible and you
trust i'm not a doctor
joe rogan's a doctor fauci is a doctor
but i don't think he's practicing a long
time
but the bigger question here is at what
point does a dude
doing what he wants to do talking to his
friends on camera
go from just being able to say whatever
he wants
to actually having societal expectations
placed upon him
joe rogan is the like
the podcast i don't know what you know
for a while it was the biggest podcast
in the world
i don't know if we can still say that
anymore to be completely honest because
he went exclusive with spotify so i'm
sure that affected things
but look man with great power comes
great responsibility that's why i'm just
like talk to your doctor
and i said in my segment i was like
there's probably a lot of medical things
i would opine on when it comes to like
injuries or something
that probably wouldn't matter but
considering we have this major hotbed of
political conflict and media
ridiculousness
i just say the easiest way to diffuse
all of it is hey talk to your doctor
you know it's like we don't got to argue
about it the tv doctor is not the person
you want to be you want to be going to a
for advice
but i could see him having fouchy and
another doctor on
together that have like alternate views
to talk about it
in front of him but i think it's smart
to not become the arbiter
uh decision maker in this case this is
such a
it's just simple let's just talk to your
doctor let's read some more super chats
all right
here we go edvark says we're in a new
age of persecution similar to
mccarthyism in the salem witch trials
those who don't learn from history are
doomed to repeat it
sad days indeed it does feel like wait
wait a second hold on a second
mccarthy he was right
the witch trials people were wrong they
weren't actually witches
but mccarthy said that hollywood and
universities were being taken over by
the communists
i think that guy was right
in hindsight was he not correct i think
he took people out that weren't
communist
okay so some of the tactics may have
been misguided for sure right
but the general concept is that mccarthy
was right
communists have taken over our country
and they're trying to tear it apart
he was just a visionary it could i i'm
talking about i'm talking out of my ass
a tiny bit here but
the gist is right he believed the
communists were taking over the country
was gonna be bad for america
guess what dude was right and he was
right
and here we are well interesting
i feel like it's like salem witchcraft
should i have saved that one for the
after show no
i don't know that's actually an
interesting idea i never looked at it
like that before but i think
you're on something about how he how he
conducted himself and the things that
they did may not have been too
authoritarian i don't know the details
on that for sure
but i do know that he was right in his
fear of coming because
we got a good super chat here chris
brows says the national guard will
become the local police
we are under contract and cannot just
walk away from the job like a civilian
cop
they can be state or federally activated
don't have to supply
housing that's right there it is the
cops get abolished the national guard
comes out
checkpoints and barbed wire fences
everywhere and they don't need housing
and
of course this means national guard are
people who will just blindly follow any
order no matter how
no matter how sick and depraved and how
it violates constitution right
well hopefully not why though why why i
i haven't i haven't gotten there yet tim
what where i just blankly assume that
anybody with a gun in a uniform in
america is going to pee
on the constitution and shoot me let's
say
you uh i'm just i'm just too optimistic
let's say you're
you're you're in the military right
you're in the national guard and you're
standing guard and they say you got to
stand guard here right
we're worried about terror attacks ian's
walking down the street wearing that and
he's got a gun
and your commanding officer says stop
that man now
disarm him are you going to be like no
why or you're going to be like yes sir
now is that a fault of that person no
it's the banality of evil yes sir
right so the individual with a lack of
knowledge
doesn't understand the full context and
probably can't you can't give a dossier
on
ian you know to you and say read this
and then apparently he'll be gone
so do you trust your chain of command so
it's not necessarily the
infantry or ground soldier's fault right
it's the system
i get i i think there's no real solution
to it because it's not an unlawful order
to say detain someone
now if we're talking about load that
person up onto a train to a
concentration camp and they choose to do
that
the argument then becomes did they know
where they were sending this person or
were they told
detain this person and when it came to
like the the trials after world war ii
they really didn't
take any soldiers out it was only the
top commanders that they
that they punished well i mean there are
there are former nazi soldiers who are
being caught and rounded up across
around the world and have been for the
past several decades
it doesn't matter if you are nuremberg i
mean they they took out like
i mean just just right now and we're
gonna i'm gonna talk to julie kelly
tomorrow on jack murphy live on youtube
jack murphy live
that about january 6 trespassers
being held in solitary confinement due
to corona pre-trial
yeah pre-charges in some cases even and
this
people are just carrying that out
without any question i mean you're
you're right
you're right but the system must be able
to function in a way where
the people on the on the front lines get
in order and they follow them otherwise
it's just not exact function
ever and therein lies the the the break
in the system
that you could be in the national guard
and they'll say we've got
insurrection and riots so we're setting
up a security perimeter protect the seat
of the capitol
then you're armed and you're standing on
a street corner and you get word
that you've got an insurgent heading
your way take him out now now now he's
dangerous he's armed and then he and run
you see ian carrying the gun and they go
don't move don't move
and they shoot him and what are they
supposed to do
all right he's on my uh send me the
dossier so i have a full details and
then i'll cr i'll cross-reference all
everything you sent me to make sure it's
true no they have to follow the order
and then what happens is people have
their constitutional rights violated
and then these people who serve in the
military will inadvertently be part of a
system
should the system go that direction
that's why you don't want military
as civilian acting as civilian police
because they do have to follow orders
no matter what whereas cops have a lot
more liberty with
same problems discretion but they can at
least they don't they're not gonna get
like
executed they can walk off yeah yeah
yeah so
imagine this you're in the national
guard and they say
we got prisoners coming in we need you
to load them up on a train they're being
transported to a prison you'd say
okay what if would would you know that
they were being sent to guest chambers
modern day with social media kind of
some nowadays it's a little different
because you you can look on twitter and
be like oh my gosh those people that we
loaded up were
political prisoners if it's if it's like
the manhattan project was
compartmentalized
and people didn't know what they were
even building
so if you are serving under contract and
you have to follow orders
you will and you won't think twice
because you don't know what the orders
ultimately will lead to
that's that's it's that's just the way
it is
so people will have their rights
violates end of story if things keep
going the way they're going for sure
sounds like scale is the problem scale
is the problem when things become too
big in scale
then you know sort of unconstitutional
orders or negative orders or commands
can get passed through this scale and be
executed even though they may be
blatantly false and wrong
scale is the issue localism and
decentralization is the antidote
all right jmack says shout out to the
quartering and what he did for the
holiday inn guy this week
love him or hate him jeremy does good
things that is right you saw the holiday
inn guy he like had a panic attack
breakdown yeah yeah quartering raised a
bunch of money i think for him good for
you yeah good job buddy
then handed it over to him yep
bottled water says seriously tim no bs i
spent a decade in the military
and have friends who do things that
would make you cry have me on and i will
blow your mind from combat rules to
things they won't acknowledge
well i will say we are planning a bunch
of new shows so maybe
we'll have something off youtube website
only that's like you know
deep sit-down interviews with people who
have served and and war stories and cop
stories and a lot of stories
have signed nda as soldiers and stuff so
that they're yeah and the ones who can
will they're not supposed to
oh the horror
caper 2x says tim you create strongmen
then invite sedition
how that helps what's missing from your
rants it only applies to democrat
communities there is there is a big red
world out there how are they doing
i don't understand
i was confused straw man's all i got out
of there
black tsar says the flash point to
expect will be over an individual
aggrieved by the state's failure to
manage riots
and who has acted in self-defense
himself who will not thereafter allow
the state to arrest them
and whose local community agrees and
acts so they will not be arrested
like in weaver vendetta where
so you have uh the inspector he's
telling the story of like what's
what's happening and he's like and then
someone will do something stupid and it
shows the little girl wearing the mask
skipping and the cop shoots her and then
everyone shows up with bats and starts
beating the cop
because when people finally break down
and say we don't care anymore
cal rittenhouse was dangerous for for
the establishment
and that's why i said i don't think the
intelligence agencies have control over
anything i think they're failing and
they're bad at their jobs
because the written house thing is the
most incendiary thing in the country in
my opinion well the george floyd thing
no i mean that thing nope it's such a
threat
absolutely not when george floyd
happened it was conservatives and
democrats united in anger
entirely like 99 system down no ready to
support the state
who came in and prosecuted chauvin and
then they celebrate the state
they're cheering for the state well but
they were burning buildings and
cities and things right and then when
the state came in and said and now we'll
give you what you want they went yay
government but the written house thing
is ripping the rip ripping the factions
in twain
and you're going to have people who are
like what he did was clearly
self-defense and we all saw it
and there's no justice anymore i think
the issue there is it's not going to get
much media
that media attack the written house
thing yeah when when they where
when they are you nuts no written house
according to the left no they have they
have sorry they have to kill
kill the full force in way unwritten
house why
because he's a white boy with a gun that
took the law and defense of property
into his own hands
can't be having that now dawg what do
you think will pariah
must have heard him will they are the
left narrative
is that kyle rittenhouse took a gun
across state lines to hunt
down activists who were peacefully
protesting
and then brutally murdered them in cold
blood the real story is that he was a
lifeguard in kenosha
who was given a gun by one of his
friends in wisconsin and asked by the
property owners to help defend the area
and he tent he
he rendered aid to some of the rioters
who almost blew up a gas station
and then he defended himself when he was
attacked but that's only if you've
actually watched the analysis and know
this
the propagandists have a lot of power
and regular people genuinely believe
he's a white supremacist who is hunting
down peaceful black lives matter
protesters
dude i wasn't there live that night but
i watched
this various streams live that night
like
i know that there's more information and
more data dude but i watched every
little bit unfold the tensions at the
gas station
rise that the n-word guy who got killed
who was screaming the white guy kept
screaming n-word over and over and over
again that guy who ended up getting shot
later
i watched him run down the street being
chased people
hitting him with the skateboard and
falling down shooting a guy who's
reaching for i mean
and then if you just if you just donate
money
in support of due process you get fired
from your job
yep john adams today
would be a pariah for representing the
english in the boston massacre
oh wow yeah that's awesome he did that
because he believed in due process and
the right to a fair trial he also got
them off
right he also got them off because they
deserve to be right
and so in this case you can't even that
that's american
yeah that's patriotism
donating ten dollars or fifteen or
twenty five dollars to a to a due
process fund basically a legal defense
fund
for someone unconvicted of a crime
that's american
but now i can't remember was it a cop or
somebody got fired
because he donated a small money amount
of money to a guy
to hire a lawyer to defend him for a due
process i think right now is going to
get life in prison
we were talking to andrew branca and he
was saying that you know it's two counts
of murder so that would be life
and do you think the jurors are going to
do
anything for that for for for written
house well they shouldn't
they should just do what's right but
but what i mean is i'm not saying they
would do him a favor
i'm saying do you think they would do
anything that's beneficial to him and
of course not they're gonna walk through
the burning rubble that is kenosha
and they're gonna go into the trial and
they're gonna be like i don't i don't
care about the evidence can i just say
guilty and go home because otherwise
they're gonna burn my house down
right that's why bronco was saying they
they're pushing it back further and
further back
so that it's further away from the
emotional right trauma of the moment
derek chovin was a cop who was trying to
arrest someone
and that person died and they they went
nuts
kyle rittenhouse according to the left
is a white supremacist who hunted down
peaceful black lives matter protesters
their narrative on written house is
several orders of magnitude more
insane and dramatic than anything
related to derek chovin
yes they are they they're not going to
throw the book at the guy they're going
to throw the library at him
i guess i would hope that it comes out
in court that he's not
he wasn't a murderer they didn't hunt
people did the mainstream media
accurately report on the defense during
the chauvin trial
i don't think so they didn't watch it to
be honest they didn't
so do you think the mainstream media is
going to accurately report on the
defense in the written house trial no of
course not
they're gonna there's gonna be headline
after headline prosecution witness says
written house is a white supremacist
terrorist and then when the defense
comes out
and they say here's proof of him
actually a post he made where he opposes
white supremacy the media won't report
it
and then regular people will see this
and they'll freak out and they'll demand
you know quote unquote justice and
they'll start setting fires
and the jurors are going to be like i
just didn't want to go through the riots
and the destruction again
i was scared someone would come to my
house and retaliate i think my guess is
that there's
way less animosity towards him than
there was towards
chauvin because of unfortunately the
color of the skin of the guy that
chauvin killed
so i don't think there's going to be as
much hate towards that kid
well let's read some more we got bailey
and he says i live in alaska and
currently you get paid to live here
but democrat and dems disguised as
republicans have been trying to take it
away
because they're greedy and don't know
how to diversify our economy outside of
oil and yet demand their luxuries
well there you go they pay you to live
in alaska huh
not bad good to know you must really
suck dude
sean murphy says legit podcast and
all y'all are great thanks for doing
what you do ian's graphene dream free
the code
legit bat podcast graphene world
incoming dude you're gonna have touch
screen wallpaper
i mean don't they already have that
maybe but it's gonna be like spray paint
you'll spray it on your walls and it'll
become a touch screen computer
very cool do it
super chats tim super chat me let's see
what we got i didn't get it
trying to find good ones you know i'll
just start spouting off technology no no
no
spray paint windows we've made it
through a whole episode without you
saying your number one
center square drinking game item oh
right
are we gonna make it we're gonna make if
you're talking about the federal reserve
because it's been on my mind i just
haven't brought i mean you wanna talk
about the global economic order
and the real root of this tim super chat
me quick
john rourke says i'm a six year police
veteran i love my job and don't want to
have to find something else to do
yeah there is a move to defund san
antonio police department vote against
proposition proposition
is that b yeah on may 1st fellow san
antonions
hmm i don't know i'm conflicted san
antonio isn't one of those
people aren't taking responsibility for
their communities so supporting police
departments at this point is to continue
the track we're on where
people just hand off responsibility to
democrats
i'm not a fan of that anymore i've never
been a fan of that and i think the
problem is so long as police keep saying
i love my job i don't want to leave then
regular people are going to be like i
don't got to do anything as a cop this
police department
i don't i don't i don't need to bear
arms so neither do you then they go and
vote for democrats and take my guns away
because
they won't take responsibility for their
own safety and security
so how about we don't abolish the police
but we do defund them dramatically
so that we have after someone breaks
into your home or commits a crime the
police come for the administration
administrative portion but you're
responsible for your own security and
safety
i've been thinking about it i think
there's a difference between not getting
involved with it
and actively uh campaigning to have them
defunded
so i get it that particularly with you
tim that you're you're angry with the
situation you feel like they're being
used for ill
but to actively no i think the police
are supporting a corrupt system on
purpose at this point
some of them but probably not that guy
that that loves his job it's the benelli
sucked to be a cop in the in the in the
empire
i worked for fusion and when they told
me they were corrupt i said i want to
leave
right now a lucrative very
very lucrative contract with disney and
i went to the president and said why am
i here
can i end my contract and they said
let's think about it
they put me in golden handcuffs dumped a
massive bonus in my bank account
and i said the moment you say we're done
i'm out
i tried quitting a year into my contract
because they were a crooked company
i could have taken all that sweet sweet
money and lived in luxury in miami
like everybody else i don't want to do
that and there are people right now
they're saying but i love my job oh it
was fantastic
i had a budget where i could fly
anywhere in the world whenever i wanted
i got they actually paid for me to go on
a luxury cruise
with all of these celebrities i got to
hang out with with
lady gaga's manager and a bunch of other
crazy industry
industry insiders and meet these super
wealthy people who are just laughing and
on this massive cruise ship
going to uh going to nassau in the
bahamas and it was like a 10 grand
cruise
i could have stayed i don't want to do
it not for the money
but i don't think that guy's doing it
for the money i i loved
traveling the world and reporting on
serious issues and making documentaries
and i was in a position where they were
giving me ridiculous amounts of money to
do it
and i said i'm not going to to support a
corrupt and broken system
i won't so break my contract they said
no she said okay i'm chilling
kept me in golden handcuffs then it
ended and i left and i started my own
thing
this is why you have to be financially
independent it is the only way to remain
mentally emotionally and spiritually
independent
as well all right steph mlb says tim
could you cover the increasing violence
at the border
been following violence and have even
spoken to people in cartels since living
in mexico
look up the case of the satanic
sacrifice of america of american
mark kilroy this needs more attention
and coverage
timkest.com is going to be launching a
newsroom
and we're going to start producing
minidocks and stuff like that so
we absolutely will be looking to send
crews down to to cover the stuff
it'll be uh it'll be a whole lot of fun
all right we'll just do a
a couple more super chats gobstopper
gob stomper beau says 70 percent of the
military is right-leaning
and as a weekend warrior myself we have
had this conversation about unlawful
orders
we have a duty to disobey unlawful
orders fyi the militia
10 u.s code 246 right
but stopping someone from carrying a
weapon isn't necessarily an unlawful
order
telling someone to arrest someone not an
unlawful order telling someone to get
into a train
not an unlawful order that's it
they don't tell you hey will you go put
this person into a death camp
then you'd be like no i won't okay
they'll say hey this person is going to
jail you go okay
fine by me all right let's see let's
just do uh
one more aileen jesus hey tim check out
the canadian prime minister trying to
pass a bill suppressing civilian speech
on social media i will check that out
and bill hughes last one he says the
raid on giuliani is a move to destroy
evidence
interesting yeah that crossed my mind
yeah all right everybody
make sure you follow us over here at tim
cast irl on instagram
at tim cast irl and on facebook at
facebook.com
tim cast irl that's right we're using
the big platforms because
we're hoping to uh i guess grow the
website and use the platforms the best
our abilities to drive more to the
website
and then build something massively
independent and sharing segments on
facebook helps us do that
you can also follow me at timcast and my
other youtube channels are
youtube.comcast and youtube.comcastnews
this show is live
monday to friday 8pm so we will we will
be back tomorrow thanks for now
everybody and jack i think you got stuff
a shout out i have got stuff going on
for sure
tomorrow i'm interviewing julie kelly
we're gonna go over the january
sixth indictments accusations what's
been happening to all the people who've
been detained
and then on friday i'm interviewing joe
kent a congress
congressional candidate from oregon i
believe who's got a tremendous story
you can see all that at jack murphy live
on on facebook
youtube jack murphy live actually jack
murphy live all over the place facebook
twitter
instagram minds rumble and a few others
as well so i'll see you there thanks
very much i just found out that jack
murphy used to be a cage fighter
no no no back that up muay thai
champion amateur muay thai champion
two-time north american
wka kickboxing champion yes i have
trained mma i have fought in a cage but
not in a sanctioned fight
i have trained with ufc cage fighters
but not an official
cage fighter a sanction case i am not
taking that just a
spider in my heart yes for you stolen
valor
i am not taking that stolen battle sorry
i got enough valor to go around
it's pretty hardcore hey follow me at
crossland.net and i'm at ian cross on
all over social media send me a message
anytime hit me up on twitter i love
interacting with everybody thank you
guys for coming
smash the like button crush it yes do it
make up the difference in viewers that
we lost to crowder
please do it for me guys they're all
going to buy
no i'm sure it wasn't because of biden
i'm sure it was because of crowders
right when you started anyway i'm not
annoyed at all you can follow me at
sourpatchlids on twitter and help me
beat
sourpatch kids and followers we will be
back at timcast.com and exclusive
members only segment
we will see you all there bye guys
you